THE STOCK MARKET THIS MORNING IS
UP 35 POINTS.
HERE IS THE PRESIDENT FOLLOWED
BY THE VICE-PRESIDENT.
WE WILL LISTEN TO THE PRESIDENT
TOGETHER.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I HAD A VERY GOOD TELEPHONE
CONVERSATION EXTREMELY GOOD WITH
SENATOR SCHUMER WORKING ON
VARIOUS ELEMENT OF THE DEAL AND
THE DEMOCRATS WANT SOMETHING TO
HAPPEN AND THE REPUBLICANS
LIKEWISE WANT SOMETHING TO
HAPPEN.
I THINK IT WILL.
I SPOKE WITH MITCH MCCONNELL AT
LENGTH.
THIS TREMENDOUS SPIRIT TO GET
SOMETHING DONE.
MY CONVERSATION WAS VERY GOOD
WITH SENATOR SCHUMER.
I THINK YOU ALL FOR JOINING US.
I WILL PROVIDE AN UPDATE WHAT WE
ARE DOING TO MINIMIZE THE EXACT
OF THE CHINESE VIRUS ON
STUDENTS.
WITH SCHOOLS CLOSED.
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
WON'T ENFORCE STANDARDIZED
TESTING REQUIREMENTS FOR
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL TO HIGH SCHOOL
FOR THE CURRENT YEAR.
THEY HAVE BEEN THROUGH A LOT.
THEY HAVE BEEN GOING BACK AND
FORTH.
SCHOOL IS OPEN OR NOT OPEN.
SUSPEND ALL STANDARDIZED
TESTING.
WE WON'T ENFORCE.
THAT YOU CAN LET THE PEOPLE
KNOW.
A LOT OF THE STUDENTS WILL BE
HAPPY.
SOME PROBABLY NOT.
IT'S ONE OF THOSE THINGS.
UNFORTUNATE CIRCUMSTANCE.
WE HAVE TEMPORARILY WAVED
INTERESTS ON FEDERAL STUDENT
LOANS.
THEY FEEL WILL BE HAPPY TO HEAR
THAT.
I INSTRUCTED THEM TO TAKE THAT
ACTION IMMEDIATELY.
TODAY WE DIRECTED FEDERAL LENDER
TO ALLOW BORROWOERS TO SUSPEND
STUDENT LOANS WITHOUT PENALTY
FOR 60 DAYS.
IF WE NEED MORE WE WILL EXTEND
THAT PERIOD OF TIME.
WE GAVE THEM STRONG
INSTRUCTIONS.
WE TEMPORARILY WAVED ALL
INTEREST ON FEDERALLY HELD
STUDENT LOANS.
THAT'S A BIG THING.
THAT WILL MAKE A LOT OF STUDENTS
HAPPY.
WE HAVE MORE TO COME ON STUDENT
LOANS.
MORE GOOD NOWS BUT WE WILL DO
THAT AT A DIFFERENT TIME.
THIS MORNING THE TREASURY
DEPARTMENT ANNOUNCED WE ARE
MOVING TAX DAY FROM APRIL 15th
TO JULY 15th.
SO THAT PEOPLE WILL HAVE TIME
AND PEOPLE WILL BE ABLE TO
HOPEFULLY BY THAT TIME WE WILL
HAVE PEOPLE GETTING BACK TO
THEIR LIVES.
FAMILIES AND BUSINESSES WILL
HAVE EXTRA TIME TO FILE WITH NO
INTEREST OR PENALTIES.
WE ARE GETTING RID OF INTEREST
AND PENALTIES.
HOWEVER, IF YOU HAVE REFUNDS OR
CREDIT YOU MAY STILL FILE.
YOU CAN FILE EARLY IF YOU ARE
OWED MONEY BY THE IRS.
OTHER THAN THAT, WE ARE MOVING
IT OUT TO JULY 15th.
NO INTEREST OR PENALTIES.
THE NEW DATE IS JULY 15th.
OUR TEAM WILL PROVIDE AN UPDATE
ON OUR EFFORT TO PREVENT THE
TRANSMISSION OF VIRUS ACROSS THE
BORDERS.
I WATCHED WHAT HAPPENED IN
CALIFORNIA WITH GOVERNOR NEWSOME
AND THIS MORNING WITH GOVERNOR
CUOMO.
THEY ARE TAKING STRONG STEPS AND
I APPLAUD THEM.
I WOULD SAY BASED ON THE CALL,
WITH RESPECT TO VIRTUALLY EVERY
GOVERNOR ON THAT CALL, WE HAD
ALMOST ALL OF THEM IF NOT ALL OF
THEM.
AND I WOULD SAY THAT YOU COULD
SEE THE LEVEL OF RESPECT AND
WORKING TOGETHER WAS
EXTRAORDINARY.
THERE WAS NOBODY ANGRY.
NOBODY WAS UPSET.
WE WERE ABLE TO HELP THEM.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE ALL ABOUT.
WE WANT TO HELP.
WE ARE DOING THINGS A LOT OF
PEOPLE WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO DO.
THE RELATIONSHIP WITH GOVERNORS
AND THE STATES IS EXTRAORDINARY
UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE
THIS JUST CAME UPON US.
WE ARE WORKING WITH CANADA AND
MEXICO TO PREVENT THE SPREAD OF
THE VIRUS ACROSS NORTH AMERICA.
YOU HEARD WHAT WE DID YESTERDAY
WITH CANADA.
THE SECRETARY OF STATE POMPEO
WILL MAKE A STATEMENT HAVING TO
DO WITH MEXICO AND THE BORDER.
AND CHAD LIKEWISE WILL MAKE A
STATEMENT.
THIS IS A JOINT COMPREHENSIVE
EFFORT IN COLLABORATION WITH OUR
NEIGHBORS.
ALL OF THOSE MEASURES THAT WE
ARE PUTTING IN PLACE WILL
PROTECT THE HEALTH OF ALL 3
NATIONS AND REDUCE THE INCENTIVE
FOR A MASS GLOBAL MIGRATION THAT
WOULD DEPLETE THE HEALTHCARE
RESOURCES NEEDED FOR OUR PEOPLE.
SO WE ARE WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH MEXICO AND VERY, VERY
CLOSELY WITH CANADA.
AND THE RELATIONSHIP HAS NEVER
BEEN BETTERS.
WE ARE ALL WORKING TOWARDS THE
GAME GOAL.
OUR NATION'S TOP HEALTHCARE
OFFICIALS ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE GREAT PUBLIC HEALTHS
CONSEQUENCES OF MASS,
UNCONTROLLED CROSS-BORDER
MOVEMENT.
THAT WOULD MOSTLY DURING THIS
GLOBAL PANDEMIC.
EVERY WEEK OUR BORDER AGENTS
COUNTER THOUSANDS OF UNSCREENED
ENTRIES FROM DOZENS OF
COUNTRIES.
WE HAVE HAD THIS PROBLEM FOR
DECADES.
YOU KNOW THE STORY.
NOW IT'S A NATIONAL EMERGENCY
AND ALL OF THE OTHER THINGS WE
HAVE DECLARED, WE CAN DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
WE ARE TAKING A VERY STRONG HOLD
OF THAT.
WE HAVE BEFORE, BUT THIS IS A
LEVEL NOBODY EVER APPROACHED.
IN NORMAL TIMES THE MASSIVE
FLOWS PLACED A BURDEN ON THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
BUT THIS COULD CREATE A MASSIVE
STORM TO THE PUBLIC AT LARGE.
LEFT UNCHECKED THIS WOULD
CRIPPLE OUR IMMIGRATION SYSTEM.
OVERWHELM OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM,
AND SEVERELY DAMAGE OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY.
WE WON'T LET THAT HAPPEN.
WE HAVE A LOT OF INFORMATION.
WE WILL DISCUSS THAT IN A
MOMENT.
TO CONFRONT PUBLIC HEALTH
DECREES.
THE CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL
AND PREVENTION IS EXERCISING ITS
AUTHORITY UNDER TITLE 42 OF THE
U.S. CODE TO GIVE CUSTOMERS AND
BORDER PROTECTION THE TOOLS IT
NEEDS TO PREVENT THE VIRUS
COMING THROUGH THE NORTHERN AND
SOUTHERN BORDERS.
WE ARE TREATING THE BORDERS
EQUALLY.
A LOT OF PEOPLE SAY THEY ARE NOT
TREATED EQUALLY.
WELL, THEY ARE.
AS WE DID WITH CANADA WE ARE
WORKING WITH MEXICO TO IMPLEMENT
NEW RULES AT PORTS OF ENTRY TO
SUSPEND NON-ESSENTIAL TRAVEL.
MEXICO IS TAKING ACTION TO
SECURE OUR OWN SOUTHERN BORDER
AND SUSPEND AIR TRAVEL FROM
EUROPE.
SO WE ARE COORDINATING AIR
TRAVEL TO MEXICO AND TRYING TO
COME INTO THE UNITED STATES.
THE ACTIONS WE ARE TAKING
TOGETHER WITH OUR NORTH AMERICAN
PARTNERS WILL SAVE COUNTLESS
LIVES.
AT THE CONCLUSION OF MY REMARKS.
SECRETARY AZAR AND POMPEO AND
WOLF, WE ARE GOING TO BE ALSO
TAKING SOME QUESTIONS WITH TONY
AND DEBRA WHOM YOU HAVE GOTTEN
TO KNOW VERY WELL.
THEY WILL BE DISCUSSING CERTAIN
THINGS.
I THINK YOU WILL FIND THEM OF
GREAT INTEREST.
WE WILL BE PROVIDING TREMENDOUS
AMOUNTS OF DETAILS OVER THE
COMING DAYS.
A LOT WILL BE PROVIDED RIGHT NOW
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO FIND OUT
ABOUT IT.
>> THIS HAS BEEN A WEEK OF
RESOLUTE ACTION
TREMENDOUS
RELATIONSHIPS HAVE
DEVELOPED.
PEOPLE THAT FRANKLY DIDN'T GET
ALONG.
PEOPLE THAT DIDN'T LIKE EACH
OTHER THAT ARE NOW WORKING
TOGETHER.
MAYBE EVEN IN SOME CASES
LEARNING ABOUT EACH OTHER AND
LIKING EACH OTHER.
I INVOKED THE DEFENSE PRODUCTION
ACT.
AND LAST NIGHT, WE PUT IT INTO
GEAR.
WE MOVED TO THE NATIONAL
RESPONSE COORDINATION CENTER TO
THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF ACTIVITY.
IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT WE
DID, THE LEVEL OF ACTIVATION HAS
BEEN INCREASED TO A GREAT ONE
LEVEL.
WHICH IS THE HIGHEST LEVEL.
WE ARE PROVIDING HISTORIC
SUPPORT TO SMALL BUSINESSES AND
TO THE STATES.
NORMALLY, THEY DO THIS
THEMSELVES.
BUT BECAUSE OF THE MAGNITUDE OF
IT, THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
GOTTEN VERY MUCH INVOLVED IN
TERMS OF GETTING THE EQUIPMENT
THEY NEED.
IT IS A RESPONSIBILITY THAT THEY
HAVE.
IT DELIVERING THE STAKES A LOT.
THAT'S WHY THE GOVERNORS HAVE
BEEN VERY IMPRESSED.
WE ENACTED LEGISLATION OF
GUARANTEED SICK LEAVE AT NO COST
TO EMPLOYERS.
SO THEY GET PAID SICK LEAVE AT
NO COST TO EMPLOYERS.
WE ARE ACCELERATING THE USE OF
NEW DRUG TREATMENTS.
WE ARE DOING LEGISLATION TO GIVE
PAYMENTS TO HARDWORKING FAMILIES
THROUGHOUT OUR COUNTRY.
AMERICANS ARE RALLYING TOGETHER
TO TREAT THE UNSEEN ENEMY.
STRIKING OUR NATION.
WE SEE THE TRUE GREATNESS OF THE
AMERICAN CHARACTER.
WE ARE SEEING THAT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE TALKING
ABOUT THAT.
141 COUNTRIES FROM WHAT THEY ARE
TELLING ME.
THEY ARE WORKING VERY UNIFIED
WITH US.
I CAN SAY A GOOD NUMBER OF THEM.
IT'S DOCTORS AND NURSES ARE
WORKING TO HEAL THE SICK.
THEY ARE DELIVERING MEALS TO THE
NEEDY.
TRUCKERS ARE MAKING THE LONG
HAUL.
WORKING WITH THE BIG STORES AND
THE BIG CHAINS.
WALMART.
THEY HAVE BEEN FANTASTIC.
AND OTHERS HAVE ALL BEEN
FANTASTIC.
WE HAVE MADE IT MUCH EASIER FOR
THEM TO STOCK.
WE ARE A LIFTING RESTRICTION SO
THAT THEY CAN GET THEIR TRUCKS
ON TIME.
WE ARE SEEING VERY FEW EMPTY
SHELVES.
AND YET THE AMOUNT OF VOLUME
THAT THEY ARE DOING IS
UNPRECEDENTED BECAUSE PEOPLE
WANT TO HAVE WHAT THEY HAVE TO
HAVE.
WHAT THEY FEEL THEY HAVE TO
AND THEY ARE ALSO BUYING IN THE
SLIGHTLY QUANTITIES, WHICH IS
GOOD BECAUSE WE ARE NOT GOING
ANYWHERE.
WE ARE GOING TO BE HERE.
SO I WANT TO THANK ALL OF THOSE
VERY GREAT COMPANIES WERE
WORKING SO WELL.
THEY ARE COMING TOGETHER.
AND THANKS TO THE SPIRIT OF OUR
PEOPLE, WE WILL WIN THIS WORK.
WE ARE GOING TO WIN THIS WAR.
AMERICA WILL TRIUMPH, AND
AMERICA WILL RISE HIGHER THAN
EVER BEFORE.
WE WILL BE STRONGER THAN EVER
BEFORE, AND WE LEARNED A LOT.
WE'VE LEARNED A LOT ABOUT
RELYING ON OTHER COUNTRIES.
AND I CAN SAY THAT I THINK THAT
IS IN A VERY GOOD AND VERY BAD
WAY.
SOME GOOD THINGS CAME OUT OF IT,
AND SOME NOT SO GOOD THINGS.
SO I WOULD LIKE TO MOVE NOW TO
INVITE OUR TEAM TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON THE NEW MEASURES
TO PREVENT A VIRAL SPREAD AT OUR
BORDERS.
AND I WILL START BY ASKING THE
SECRETARY OF STATE POMPEO TO
SPEAK.
HE IS DOING A GREAT JOB.
LIKE EVERYONE ELSE, HE HAS BEEN
WORKING VERY LONG AND HARD.
AND HE IS DOING MORE NORMAL JOBS
OF SECRETARY OF STATE.
BUT HE GOT TIED INTO THIS LIKE
EVERYBODY ELSE.
HE HAS BEEN DOING A FANTASTIC
JOB.
>> THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
BEFORE I ADDRESS THE EFFORTS
THAT WE HAVE BEEN ENGAGING AND
AGAINST THE CHINESE VIRUS, I
WANT TO ASK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
AS PRESIDENT TRUMP JUST SAID,
THE PRIORITY IS FOCUSED ON THE
OTHER DIPLOMATIC CHALLENGES
AROUND THE WORLD.
THOSE INCLUDED AFGHANISTAN,
HOLDING THE IRANIAN REGIME
ACCOUNTABLE.
A COUNTERTERRORISM EFFORTS
AGAINST ISIS REMAIN A PRIORITY
FOR OUR TEAM HERE NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY REMAINS THE PROTECTION
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE ARE VERY FOCUSED ON IT.
I WANT TO THANK MY TEAM WORKING
LONG HOURS ALL AROUND THE WORLD
TO TAKE CARE OF AMERICANS.
WE WILL TALK ABOUT THAT MORE IN
JUST A LITTLE BIT.
YOU HAVE ALL SEEN DR. BURKE IS
WITH ME.
THEY ARE DOING GREAT WORK.
I WANT TO GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO
ALL STATE DEPARTMENT TEAMS HERE
IN WASHINGTON AND AROUND THE
WORLD THAT ARE DOING OVERTIME TO
HELP US PUSH BACK AGAINST THIS
PANDEMIC.
UNDER THE PRESIDENT'S LEADERSHIP
THIS WEEK, WE HAVE TO TAKE
IMPORTANT STEPS.
FIRST, AS PRESIDENT TRUMP
ANNOUNCED, THE UNITED STATES AND
CANADA JOINTLY AGREED TO
RESTRICT ALL NONESSENTIAL
TRAFFIC ACROSS OUR BORDER.
THIS DECISION GOES INTO EFFECT
TONIGHT AT MIDNIGHT.
THE RESTRICTIONS THAT WE
REVIEWED AFTER 30 DAYS.
THEY EXCLUDE TRAFFIC AND
MOVEMENT ACROSS THE BORDER.
OTHER ESSENTIAL REASONS.
WE ARE GRATEFUL TO HAVE SUCH AN
OUTSTANDING FRIEND TO THE NORTH
WHO IS AS COMMITTED AS WE ARE TO
DEFEATING THIS VIRUS.
I ALSO WANTED TO ANNOUNCE TODAY
THAT THE UNITED STATES AND
MEXICO HAVE AGREED TO RESTRICT
NONESSENTIAL TRAVEL THROUGHOUT
OUR SHARED BORDER.
BOTH COUNTRIES KNOW THE
IMPORTANCE OF WORKING TOGETHER
TO LIMIT THE SPREAD OF THE VIRUS
AND ENSURE THE COMMERCE THAT
SUPPORTS OUR ECONOMY CONTINUES
TO KEEP FLOWING.
THE UNITED STATES IS GLAD TO
HAVE A FRIEND THAT IS WORKING
SIDE-BY-SIDE WITH US IN THE
FIGHT.
SECRETARY WOLF WILL TALK A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THE
DETAILS OF HOW WE ARE WORKING
ALONGSIDE OUR PARTNERS IN MEXICO
TO HELP KEEP OUR SOUTHERN BORDER
SAFE AND SECURE AS WELL.
ON ANOTHER NOTE, YESTERDAY, THE
STATE DEPARTMENT ISSUED A LEVEL
FOR GLOBAL TRAVEL ADVISORY.
THIS MEANS THAT ALL
INTERNATIONAL TRAVEL FOR U.S.
CITIZENS SHOULD BE AVOIDED.
IN COUNTRIES WHERE COMMERCIAL
DEPARTURE, OPTIONS REMAIN
AVAILABLE.
U.S. CITIZENS WHO RESIDE IN THE
UNITED STATES SHOULD ARRANGE FOR
IMMEDIATE RETURN TO THE
UNITED STATES, UNLESS THEY ARE
PREPARED TO REMAIN ABROAD FOR AN
EXTENDED PERIOD BACK OF TIME.
IF YOU CHOOSE TO TRAVEL, YOUR
PLANS VERY WELL MAY BE SEVERELY
DISRUPTED.
FINALLY, I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE DISINFORMATION THAT PEOPLE
ARE SAYING ON TWITTER ANSWER ON
THE WORLD.
COMING FROM GOVERNMENTS.
SOME OF IT COMING FROM OTHER
INDIVIDUALS.
I JUST URGE ANYONE, IF YOU ARE
SEEING INFORMATION THAT SUGGESTS
THAT VIRUS CAME FROM THE
UNITED STATES MILITARY,
INFORMATION ABOUT LOCKDOWNS,
EVERYONE SHOULD ENSURE THAT
WHERE THEY TURN TO FOR
INFORMATION IS A RELIABLE SOURCE
AND NOT A BAD ACTOR TRYING TO
CREATE INFORMATION THAT THEY
KNOW IS WRONG.
THIS IS A TOUGH FIGHT.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE TOUGH.
OUR DIPLOMATIC TEAMS ARE WORKING
TO HELP US SAVE HOME AND ABROAD.
THE GLOBAL LEADERSHIP THAT
AMERICA HAS ALWAYS DELIVERED HAS
BEEN GREAT TO SEE COUNTRIES
AROUND THE WORLD RALLY BEHIND
WHAT WE ARE DOING.
>> President Trump: THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
WE WILL TAKE QUESTIONS RIGHT
AFTER THIS.
>> LET ME START OFF BY THANKING
THE PRESIDENT AND THE
VICE PRESIDENT FOR THEIR
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP AND
COMMITMENT TO PROTECTING THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE DURING THIS
CRISIS.
EARLY ON, THE PRESIDENT AGAIN
TOOK UNPRECEDENTED ACTIONS TO
RESTRICT TRAVEL FROM AREAS
AFFECTED WITH THE CORONAVIRUS.
AND TO DATE, WE HAVE SCREENED
OVER 200,000 INDIVIDUALS COMING
BACK FROM THOSE AFFECTED
COUNTRIES.
THIS HAS BEEN AN IMMENSE
UNDERTAKING.
ONE THAT THE MEN AND WOMEN OF
DHS HAVE SUCCESSFULLY
ACCOMPLISHED.
TODAY'S ANNOUNCEMENT IS YET
ANOTHER ONE OF THE EXTRAORDINARY
STEPS THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
TAKEN TO ENSURE THE SAFETY OF
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
BEFORE I COMMENT ON THE CDC
ORDER THAT I'M SURE
SECRETARY AZAR WILL ELABORATE
ON, LET ME TALK ABOUT WHAT
SECRETARY POMPEO AND OTHERS HAVE
MADE REGARDING CROSS-BORDER
TRAVEL.
AS WE CONTINUE TO EVALUATE
MEASURES THAT REDUCE RISK AND
PREVENT FURTHER SPREAD, IT ONLY
MAKES SENSE THAT WE HAVE LOOKED
AT THE MEASURES THAT ARE
NEIGHBORS TO THE NORTH AND SOUTH
ARE UNDERTAKING.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THOSE PARTNERS SINCE THE
EARLIEST DAYS OF THIS VIRUS.
AGAIN, AS THE PRESIDENT SAID
EARLIER THIS WEEK AND
SECRETARY POMPEO, WE ISSUED AN
AGREEMENT WITH BOTH CANADA AND
MEXICO TO LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
TRAVEL ACROSS OUR LAND BORDERS.
LET ME BE CLEAR THAT NEITHER OF
THESE AGREEMENTS WITH CANADA OR
MEXICO APPLIES TO LAWFUL TRADE
OR COMMERCE.
ESSENTIAL COMMERCE ACTIVITIES
WILL NOT BE IMPACTED.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN A
STRONG AND SECURE ECONOMIC
SUPPLY CHAIN ACROSS OUR BORDERS.
A FEW EXAMPLES OF ESSENTIAL
TRAVEL INCLUDE BUT CERTAINLY NOT
LIMITED TO INDIVIDUALS TRAVELING
FOR MEDICAL PURPOSES, TO ATTEND
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS, FOR
EMERGENCY RESPONSE PUBLIC HEALTH
SERVICES, AND THOSE INVOLVED IN
LAWFUL CROSS-BORDER TRADE.
THE AGREEMENTS WITH BOTH CANADA
AND MEXICO WILL GO INTO EFFECT
ON SATURDAY, MARCH 21ST.
FURTHERMORE, WE ARE ALSO WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH CANADA AND
MEXICO TO TAKE JOINT ACTION
REGARDING INDIVIDUALS SEEKING
ENTRY BETWEEN OUR PORTS OF
ENTRY.
THE CDC ORDER DIRECTS SUSPENSION
OF ALL INDIVIDUALS SEEKING TO
ENTER THE U.S. WITHOUT PROPER
TRAVEL DOCUMENTATION.
THAT IS FOR BOTH THE NORTHERN
AND SOUTHERN BORDERS.
THE CDC DIRECTOR HAS DETERMINED
THAT THE SPREAD OF THE
CORONAVIRUS AND BORDER PATROL
STATIONS, DETENTION FACILITIES
PRESENTS A SERIOUS DANGER TO
MIGRANTS.
OUR FRONT-LINE AGENTS, AND
OFFICERS END OF AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IT IS HELPFUL TO NOTE THAT
FOREIGN NATIONALS FROM OVER 120
DIFFERENT COUNTRIES AROUND THE
WORLD.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THOSE
HAVING CORONAVIRUS CASES.
MANY OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
ARRIVED WITH LITTLE OR NO
IDENTITY TRAVEL OR MEDICAL
DOCUMENTATION, MAKING PUBLIC
HEALTH RISK DETERMINATIONS ALL
BUT IMPOSSIBLE.
IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT THE OUTBREAK ON OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER WILL LIKELY
INCREASE THE STRAIN ON HEALTH
SYSTEMS IN OUR BORDER
COMMUNITIES, TAKING AWAY
IMPORTANT AND LIFE-SAVING
RESOURCES FROM AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
TONIGHT, MNF, WE WILL EXECUTE
THE CDC ORDER BY IMMEDIATELY
RETURNING INDIVIDUALS ARRIVING
WITHOUT DOCUMENTATIONS TO
CANADA, MEXICO, AS WELL AS A
NUMBER OF OTHER COUNTRIES
WITHOUT DELAY.
AGAIN, THEY ARE POSITIONED TO
EXECUTE THESE MEASURES AS WE
CONTINUE TO KEEP OUR BORDERS
SECURE.
BEFORE WE CONCLUDE, LET ME JUST
WRAP UP BY THANKING THE BRAVE
MEN AND WOMEN OF DHS.
ACROSS THE GOVERNMENT.
THE WORK THAT THEY DO DAY IN AND
DAY OUT TO GIVE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE SAY FROM THE CORONAVIRUS.
THE DEPARTMENT HAS A NUMBER OF
FRONT-LINE OFFICERS HAVE TESTED
POSITIVE AS WELL AS OTHERS WHO
ARE SELF QUARANTINING.
I AM DOING EVERYTHING THAT I CAN
TO PROTECT THESE PATRIOTS AS
THEY CONTINUE TO DEFEND THEIR
HOMELAND DURING THIS CRISIS.
THANK YOU.
>> President Trump: THANK YOU.
>> TODAY'S ANNOUNCEMENT IS JUST
THE LATEST IN A LONG LINE OF
BULLS, DECISIVE ACTIONS OF THE
PRESIDENT HAS TAKEN TO PROTECT
AMERICANS FROM THE CORONAVIRUS
SPREADING ACROSS OUR BORDERS.
IN JANUARY, WITHIN TWO WEEKS OF
CHINA NOTIFYING W.H.O. ABOUT THE
VIRUS, AND WITH ONLY 45 CASES IN
CHINA, WE BEGAN SCREENING
TRAVELERS FROM A WUHAN.
OVER TIME, AS OUTBREAK OF ALL,
THE RESTRICTED TRAVEL.
OUR HEALTH EXPERTS SAY THAT
THESE MEASURES HAVE BEEN TRULY
EFFECTIVE AT SLOWING THE VIRUSES
SPREAD TO OUR SHORES.
JUST THINK ABOUT THIS.
ITALY AND THE UNITED STATES BOTH
SAW THEIR FIRST TRAVEL RELATED
CASE OF CORONAVIRUS AROUND THE
EXACT SAME TIME.
THE LAST WEEK OF JANUARY.
AND YET WE HAVE HAD PRECIOUS
TIME TO CONTINUE OUR WORK AROUND
VACCINES, THERAPEUTICS, AND
OTHER PREPARATIONS, WHILE ITALY
HAS TRAGICALLY BEEN OVERWHELMED
WITH CRITICAL PATIENTS FOR
SEVERAL WEEKS NOW.
THE PRESIDENT TODAY IS TAKING
ACTION TO SLOW THE SPREAD OF
INFECTIOUS DISEASE VIA OUR
BORDER.
UNDER SECTION 362 OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH SERVICE ACT, THE CDC IS
SUSPENDING THE ADMISSION OF
CERTAIN PERSONS HEAR THEIR ENTRY
INTO THE UNITED STATES
REPRESENTS.
THIS ORDER APPLIES TO PERSONS
COMING FROM MEXICO AND CANADA.
WHO ARE SEEKING TO ENTER THE
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY.
AS IT WOULD NORMALLY BE HELD IN
CONCORD GET SETTING LIKE CUSTOMS
AND BORDER PROTECTION STATION.
IT DOES NOT APPLY TO U.S.
CITIZENS OR LAWFUL PERMANENT
RESIDENCE.
DURING THIS PANDEMIC, A NUMBER
OF HEALTH CHALLENGES ARISE WHEN
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ARRIVE AT OUR
NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN BORDERS
AND ARE TAKEN INTO IMMIGRATION
CUSTODY.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT SIGNIFICANT
NUMBERS OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
FROM THIS PAST OCTOBER THROUGH
FEBRUARY, DHS HAS PROCESSED MORE
THAN 21,000 INADMISSIBLE ALIENS
OF THE NORTHERN BORDER AND MORE
THAN 151,000 INADMISSIBLE ALIENS
AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
FACILITIES WERE NEVER DESIGNED
TO HOLD LARGE NUMBERS OF PEOPLE
AND TO PROTECT AGENTS AND
MIGRANTS FROM INFECTION.
DURING A PANDEMIC PIER NOR TO
TREAT THEM FOR A NOVEL VIRUS ARE
LARGE NUMBERS INFECTED.
THESE MIGRANTS ARE SPREADING THE
VIRUS TO OTHER MIGRANTS.
TO HEALTH CARE WORKERS.
AND EVEN THE UNITED STATES
POPULATION AS A WHOLE.
IN SUCH CIRCUMSTANCES, THE KIND
OF SOCIAL DISTANCING MEASURES AT
THE CDC AND THE PRESIDENT HAVE
RECOMMENDED ARE SIMPLY NOT
POSSIBLE.
ON TOP OF THAT, ANY RESOURCES WE
ARE USING TO REDUCE THE RISK
AMONG HEALTH CARE WORKERS AND
MIGRANTS IN THESE FACILITIES ARE
DRAWING ON AMERICAN HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM THAT IS ALREADY FIGHTING
THE CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC.
THAT IS WHY THE PRESIDENT AND
HIS ADMINISTRATION ARE TAKING
THESE IMPORTANT STEPS TO KEEP
AMERICANS AND OUR IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM SAFE FROM THESE HEALTH
RISKS.
AS PART OF OUR WHOLE
GOVERNMENT'S APPROACH TO
COMBATING THE CORONAVIRUS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT, FOR
THE WORK THAT YOU HAVE BEEN
DOING THROUGHOUT THIS CRISIS TO
SLOW THE SPREAD OF THE
CORONAVIRUS AND TO KEEP OUR
COUNTRY SAFE.
>> President Trump: THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
SO WE CONTINUE TO REVIEW THE
DATA VERY CAREFULLY FROM AROUND
THE GLOBE.
AS I KNOW MANY OF YOU ARE.
WE CONTINUE TO SEE SIGNS THAT
AGAIN, INDIVIDUALS UNDER 20, 19
AND UNDER MAY HAVE SEVERE
DISEASE, BUT THE MAJORITY HAVE
RECOVERED TO DATE.
WE STILL SEE THAT SAME TREND.
AND FRANKLY, FROM ITALY, WE ARE
SEEING ANOTHER TREND THAT THE
FATALITY SEEMS TO BE TWICE IN
EVERY AGE GROUP.
THIS SHOULD ALERT ALL OF US TO
CONTINUE OUR VIGILANCE, TO
PROTECT OUR AMERICAN VETERAN
NURSING HOMES.
THIS REQUIRES ALL OF THE
COMMUNITY, WHEN YOU SEE THE
SACRIFICES THAT MANY AMERICANS
HAVE MADE, THE SACRIFICES OF THE
SERVICE INDUSTRY HAS MADE TO
CLOSE THEIR RESTAURANTS, CLOSE
THEIR BARS, SO THAT THE SPREAD
IS DISCONTINUED.
AND THEN YOU REALLY UNDERSTAND
HOW ALL OF AMERICANS MUST MAKE
THE SAME SACRIFICE.
WE CONTINUE TO ASK YOU TO FOLLOW
THE PRESIDENTIAL GUIDELINES.
NO GROUPS COMING TOGETHER OF
MORE THAN TEN.
THAT IF ANYONE IN THE HOUSEHOLD
IS SICK, THAT EVERYONE
QUARANTINES IN THE HOUSE
ALTOGETHER.
AND THAT WE CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON
THOSE WHO HAVE THE MOST
VULNERABILITY TO THIS ILLNESS.
NOW, TO THE MOMS AND DADS OUT
THERE THAT HAVE CHILDREN WITH
IMMUNODEFICIENCIES OR OTHER
MEDICAL CONDITIONS, WE DON'T
KNOW THE LEVEL OF RISK.
AND I KNOW YOU WILL ALSO PROTECT
THEM IN THE SAME WAY.
THERE JUST IS NOT ENOUGH NUMBERS
AT THIS TIME.
TO REALLY TELL THEM IF THEY ARE
OUT ADDITIONAL RISK OR NOT.
I DON'T HAVE ANY NEW DATA.
IS SHE SEEING SOMETHING NEW.
I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT TO BE AS
HONEST WITH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AS WE CAN.
FINALLY, NO ONE IS IMMUNE.
I SOMETIMES HEAR PEOPLE ON THE
RADIO OR OTHERS TALKING ABOUT
I'M IN THE THE VIRUS.
WE KNOW IT IS HIGHLY CONTAGIOUS
TO EVERYONE.
DO NOT INTERPRET MILD OR
MODERATE DISEASE AS LACK OF
CONTAGION OR THAT YOU ARE
IMMUNE.
YOU JUST HAPPEN TO HAVE A BETTER
IMMUNE SYSTEM.
AN ABILITY TO FIGHT THE VIRUS IN
NO WAY THAT MAY BE OLDER PEOPLE
WITH EXISTING MEDICAL CONDITIONS
CAN'T.
AND THAT'S WHY IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT AT THIS MOMENT THAT
ALL OF YOU CARRY THAT MESSAGE
ABOUT THE SACRIFICES THAT MANY
HAVE MADE, PARTICULARLY OUR
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND OUR
FRONTLINE HEALTH CARE WORKERS.
THEY ARE MAKING THAT SACRIFICE
EVERY DAY SO THAT EVERY AMERICAN
CAN MOVE THROUGH THIS WELL.
FOLLOWING THE PRESIDENTIAL
GUIDELINES.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MR. PRESIDENT.
I JUST WANT TO UNDERSCORE A FEW
THINGS THAT'S I HAVE SEEN TO
THIS GROUP.
YOU MAY RECALL THAT JUST A WEEK
AGO OR SO, THE TWO PILLARS, THE
TWO ELEMENTS OF OUR ABILITY TO
CONTAIN THE SURGE OF INFECTIONS
IN THIS COUNTRY RELIES ON TWO
THINGS.
KEEP INFECTIONS COMING FROM
WITHOUT, IN.
WE HAVE BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL
DOING THAT WITH CHINA.
NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN BORDER
ISSUES.
THERE IS A REASON FOR DOING
THAT.
WE CANNOT PREVENT THE PEOPLE
FROM COMING IN.
WHEN THEY CAN ACTUALLY GO INTO
THE OTHER.
SO THAT IS IMPORTANT.
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS A
PUBLIC REASON TO DOING THAT.
THE SECOND THING I THINK IS
REALLY IMPORTANT IS WHAT
HAPPENED IN NEW YORK TODAY, WHAT
GOVERNOR CUOMO MENTIONED ABOUT
AN HOUR AGO, SOME RATHER STRONG
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED.
ESSENTIALLY ORDERS.
WE HAVE A GROUP OF
RECOMMENDATIONS AT GUIDELINES
APPLICABLE THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY.
THERE ARE PLACES, REGIONS,
STATES, CITIES IN THIS COUNTRY
THAT ARE BEING STRESSED MUCH,
MUCH MORE THAN THE COUNTRY AS A
WHOLE.
CLEARLY ONE OF THEM WAS
WASHINGTON.
ANOTHER ONE WAS CALIFORNIA.
GOVERNOR NEWSOM MADE SOME VERY
IMPORTANT, DIFFICULT DECISIONS.
TODAY, GOVERNOR CUOMO DID THE
SAME THING.
AND I WANT TO SAY, I STRONGLY
SUPPORT WHAT HE IS DOING.
AND ONE THING, AS A NEW YORKER
MYSELF.
YOU HAVE FIGURED OUT HOW MY
ACCENT, I AM FROM NEW YORK.
I KNOW WHAT NEW YORKERS CAN DO.
WE ARE TOUGH.
I WAS IN NEW YORK CITY ON
SEPTEMBER 11TH.
I KNOW WHAT THE NEW YORKERS CAN
DO.
COOPERATE WITH YOUR MAYOR.
>> THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
THE WHITE HOUSE CORONAVIRUS
TASK FORCE MET THIS MORNING.
WE CONTINUE TO BRING THE FULL
RESOURCES.
A FULL WITH OUR STATE
GOVERNMENTS.
BUSINESSES AROUND AMERICA.
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO RESPOND TO THE START
OF THE CORONAVIRUS.
AND I KNOW I CAN SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF THE PRESIDENT WHEN I SAY HOW
INSPIRED WE ARE BY THE WAY THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND BUSINESSES
ARE COMING TOGETHER TO HELP
DEFEAT THIS VIRUS AND OUR
COUNTRY.
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS ARE
PUTTING INTO PRACTICE.
WE ENCOURAGE EVERYONE, EVEN
THOSE THAT ARE NOT IN AREAS WITH
SIGNIFICANT OUTBREAK, TO REVIEW
THESE GUIDELINES OVER THE NEXT
WEEK AND THE MORE AND PUT THEM
INTO PRACTICE, AND YOU WILL
CONTINUE TO DO YOUR PART.
LATER TODAY, WE WILL BE TALKING
WITH MANUFACTURERS AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
THE PRESIDENT AND I CONTINUE TO
BE INSPIRED BY THE WAY AMERICAN
INDUSTRY IS STEPPING FORWARD.
WE HAVE BUSINESSES AROUND THE
COUNTRY THAT ARE LITERALLY
VOLUNTEERING TO RETROFIT PLANS
TO HELP US MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR
HEALTH CARE WORKERS AND SYSTEM
IN CONFRONTING THE CORONAVIRUS.
AS THE PRESIDENT MENTIONED
YESTERDAY, PUTTING FEMA IN THE
LEAD, THE EMERGENCY DECLARATION,
WE ACTUALLY MET WITH ALL OF OUR
NATIONS GOVERNORS FROM THE
COORDINATION CENTER.
THE PRESIDENT AND I, OUR ENTIRE
TEAM COULD NOT BE MORE GRATEFUL
FOR THE EFFORTS OF ALL OF OUR
GOVERNORS IN IMPLEMENTING THE
GUIDANCE THAT IS BEING ISSUED,
NOT ONLY FROM OUR TASK FORCE,
ALSO IN TAKING STRONG MEASURES
IN OUR OWN COMMUNITIES TO
PROTECT OUR CITIZENS.
WE WANT TO URGE EVERY AMERICAN
TO TAHITI OR LOCAL AUTHORITIES,
LISTEN TO THEIR GUIDANCE.
AND ALSO DO YOUR PART TO SLOW
THE SPREAD.
WE REITERATED THAT THE
PRESIDENT, BY PUTTING FEMA IN
THE LEAD, WILL CONTINUE TO
IMPLEMENT A PLAN THAT IS LOCALLY
EXECUTED, STAGE-MANAGED, AND
FEDERALLY SUPPORTED THAT PUTS T.
WE RECEIVED A REPORT TODAY AS
THE PRESIDENT MENTIONED ON OUR
LEGISLATIVE TEAM ON
CAPITOL HILL, WORKING WITH
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS OTHERS
VARY HOUR TO PASS AN ECONOMIC
RECOVERY PACKAGE THAT THE
PRESIDENT DESCRIBED.
AND WE HOPE TO SEE THE CONGRESS
ACT ON THAT EARLY NEXT WEEK.
ON THE SUBJECT OF SUPPLIES, WE
CONTINUE TO MAKE STEADY PROGRESS
ON TESTING.
THANKS TO THE PRESIDENT'S
INVOLVEMENT OF COMMERCIAL LABS.
MORE AND MORE AMERICANS ARE
BEING TESTED EVERY SINGLE DAY.
THEY WILL UPDATE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ON THE STATUS OF TESTING.
OUR STATE-BASED TESTING THAT IS
LITERALLY EXPANDING BY THE HOUR.
ON THE SUBJECT OF MEDICAL
SUPPLIES, WE CONTINUE AT THE
PRESENT INSTRUCTION TO PURSUE
EVERY MEANS TO EXPAND THE SUPPLY
OF PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
FOR THE EXTRAORDINARY AND
COURAGEOUS HEALTH CARE WORKERS
THAT ARE ADMINISTERING TO THE
NEEDS OF PEOPLE IMPACTED BY THE
CORONAVIRUS.
WE HAVE A POLICY OF PROCURING,
ALLOCATING, AS WELL AS
CONSIDERING THE RESOURCES THAT
WE HAVE IN OUR SYSTEM.
AND NOW THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS
WORKED WITH THE CONGRESS TO MAKE
INDUSTRIAL MASKS WHOLLY
AVAILABLE FOR HOSPITALS TO BE
ABLE TO PURCHASE, TO BE ABLE TO
USE AS PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT, WE
ARE MORE ENCOURAGED THAN EVER
ABOUT THE AVAILABILITY OF THOSE
IMPORTANT MASKS TO OUR
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES.
AND OVER THIS WEEKEND, WE WILL
BE ANNOUNCING A MAJOR
PROCUREMENT FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
AND 95 MASKS AS WELL.
WE ARE ALSO ENCOURAGED THAT WE
ARE FINDING AN INCREASED SUPPLY
OF VENTILATORS.
WE MENTIONED THAT WE HAVE A
FEDERAL STOCKPILE.
SOME 25,000 ON STANDBY.
BUT THAT DOESN'T COUNT THE TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF VENTILATORS THAT
ARE IN OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
BUT THE PRESIDENT HAS CHALLENGED
US TO FREE UP OTHERS FROM OTHER
SOURCES AROUND THE COUNTRY.
AND THERE ARE TWO DIFFERENT WAYS
THAT WE ARE DOING THAT.
NUMBER ONE, IN OUR RECENT
DISCUSSION WITH
ANESTHESIOLOGIST, WE HAVE
LITERALLY IDENTIFIED TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF EXISTING
VENTILATORS THAT CAN BE
RETROFITTED AND CONVERTED TV
VENTILATORS WITH PEOPLE
STRUGGLING WITH THE CORONAVIRUS.
BUT ALSO, ON THE PRESIDENT'S
BEHALF AND ON BEHALF OF OUR
TASK FORCE, WE WANT TO CONTINUE
TO ENCOURAGE EVERY AMERICAN AND
EVERY FACILITY TO POSTPONE ANY
ELECTIVE MEDICAL PROCEDURES.
THIS WILL FREE UP BED SPACE,
FREE OF HOSPITAL CAPACITY FOR
PEOPLE THAT ARE STRUGGLING WITH
THE CORONAVIRUS.
AND IT WILL ALSO FREE UP
EQUIPMENT THAT ARE HEALTH CARE
WORKERS NEED.
IT IS INSPIRING THAT WE CONTINUE
TO SEE BUSINESSES AROUND
AMERICANS ARE DONATING N95 MASKS
TO THEIR LOCAL HOSPITALS, LARGE
AND SMALL.
AND IN SOME CASES, MILLIONS OF
N95 MASKS.
I KNOW HOW GRATEFUL THE
PRESIDENT'S, AND SO ARE WE.
THE THREAT OF SERIOUS ILLNESS TO
THE AVERAGE AMERICAN REMAINS
LOW.
EVERY AMERICAN CAN DO YOUR PART
TO REDUCE THE BURDEN ON YOUR
HEALTH, ON YOUR FAMILY, THE
BURDEN ON OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM, AND ESPECIALLY THE
THREAT TO THE MOST VULNERABLE
AMONG US.
BY PUTTING INTO PRACTICE THE
PRESIDENT 15 DAYS TO SLOW THE
SPREAD.
AND AS THE PRESIDENT SAID AT THE
OUTSET OF HIS REMARKS, I KNOW
THAT MILLIONS OF AMERICANS ARE
DOING THAT JUST NOW, AND THE
GREATNESS OF THE AMERICAN
CHARACTER IS SHINING FORTH.
>> President Trump: THANK YOU,
MIKE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY, THANK YOU.
GO AHEAD.
>> YOU HAD A CALL WITH
SENATOR SCHUMER.
HE SAID THAT YOU NOW AGREE TO
ACTUALLY MAKE THOSE MEDICAL
SUPPLIES FOR A SEVERE SHORTAGE.
IS THAT WHAT YOU ARE DOING NOW?
>> President Trump: WE INVOKED
IT I THINK THE DAY BEFORE WE --
AND INVOKED IT YESTERDAY.
WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE WORKING
VERY HARD TO DO VENTILATORS AND
VARIOUS OTHER THINGS, HE ASKED.
VENTILATORS, MASKS --
>> Vice President Pence: THE
THINGS THAT WE NEED, INCLUDING
SOME OF THE VERY IMPORTANT
EMERGENCIES -- I WOULD PROBABLY
SAY VENTILATORS.
WE HAVE MILLIONS OF MASKS, WHICH
ARE COMING.
AND WHICH WILL BE DISTRIBUTED TO
THE STATES.
THE STATES ARE HAVING A HARD
TIME GETTING THEM, SO WE ARE
USING THE ACT.
IT IS VERY GOOD FOR THINGS LIKE
THIS.
WE HAVE MILLIONS OF MASKS THAT
WE HAVE ORDERED.
THEY WILL BE HERE SOON.
WE ARE HAVING THEM SHIPPED
DIRECTLY.
TO SPEAK OUT YOU ARE SIGNING
THIS BUT NOT INVOKING.
THIS IS WHAT YOU SAID YESTERDAY.
HE WOULD ONLY DO SO IN THE
WORST-CASE SCENARIO.
>> WE NEED -- IT IS NO
DIFFERENT, OTHER THAN WE NEED
CERTAIN EQUIPMENT THAT THE
STATES ARE UNABLE TO GET BY
THEMSELVES.
SO WE ARE INVOKING IT TO USE THE
POWERS OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO HELP THE STATES GET THINGS
THAT THEY NEED, LIKE THE MASKS.
LIKE THE VENTILATORS.
>> WHAT GOVERNOR CUOMO HAS DONE
IN NEW YORK, IS THERE ANY MORE
CONSIDERATION TO A NATIONAL
LOCKDOWN?
>> President Trump: I DON'T
THINK SO.
ESSENTIALLY, YOU HAVE DONE THAT
IN CALIFORNIA.
YOU HAVE DONE THAT IN NEW YORK.
THOSE ARE TWO HOTBEDS.
PROBABLY THE HOTTEST OF THEM ALL
IN TERMS OF HOT SPOTS.
I DON'T THINK SO.
YOU GO TO THE MIDWEST.
YOU GOT TO OTHER LOCATIONS, AND
THEY ARE WATCHING IT ON
TELEVISION, BUT THEY DON'T HAVE
THE SAME PROBLEMS.
THEY DON'T HAVE BY ANY MEANS THE
SAME PROBLEM.
NEW YORK, CALIFORNIA, MIAMI.
THOSE GOVERNORS ARE DOING AN
EXCELLENT JOB.
RICK DeSANTIS IN FLORIDA.
WE HAVE SOME PRETTY HOT SPOTS IN
FLORIDA TOO.
IN THE STATE OF WASHINGTON, OF
COURSE.
BUT THAT WAS LARGELY, IF YOU
LOOK AT IT, IT WAS MORE NURSING
HOMES THAT HAVE PROBLEMS LIKE
YOU WOULDN'T BELIEVE.
SO WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
GOVERNORS, AND I DON'T THINK WE
WILL EVER FIND THAT NECESSARY.
>> YOUR 15 DAY GUIDELINES, ARE
YOU HAPPY WITH THE PROGRESS --
>> President Trump: I AM HAPPY
WITH IT.
WE WILL HAVE TO SEE WHAT THE
RESULTS ARE AT THE END OF 14
DAYS, I WOULD SAY IT.
TO WHAT WE DO.
BUT I AM CERTAINLY HONORED BY
THE WAY THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
WORKING.
BECAUSE IT IS WORK.
IT IS WORKING OUT TO WORK.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME THIS HAS
EVER HAPPENED.
WE ARE WORKING OUT A FINANCIAL
PACKAGE FOR THEM SO THAT THEY
DON'T WORK.
WHOEVER HEARD OF THIS?
USUALLY YOU FIGURE OUT A
FINANCIAL PACKAGE TO GET PEOPLE
WORKING.
WE ARE ASKING PEOPLE NOT TO
WORK.
SOCIAL DISTANCING.
THAT NEW TERM THAT HAS BECOME
PROBABLY THE HOTTEST TERM THERE
IS.
NO, I AM VERY HONORED BY THE WAY
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE TAKING
THIS SO SERIOUSLY.
YES, JIM?
>> A QUESTION FOR YOU AND A
QUESTION FOR DR. FAUCI, IF I
COULD.
IT IS WEIGHTED TOO MUCH IN FAVOR
OF CORPORATIONS AND NOT
INDIVIDUALS.
WHAT DID YOUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
SENATOR SCHUMER YIELD ON THAT?
>> President Trump: I THINK
ALL OF THAT, I DON'T WANT TO
HAVE STOCK BUYBACKS.
I DON'T WANT PEOPLE SPENDING --
I DON'T WANT SOME EXECUTIVE
SAYING WE ARE GOING TO BUY
200,000 SHARES OF STOCK.
I WANT THAT TO BE FOR THE
WORKERS AND ALSO FOR THE
COMPANY, TO KEEP THE COMPANY
GOING.
I WOULD -- I MEAN, I HAVEN'T
SPOKEN TO A LOT OF THE
REPUBLICANS OR DEMOCRATS.
WE DISCUSSED IT.
AND I DON'T LIKE BUYBACKS.
I DIDN'T LIKE THEM THE FIRST
TIME.
>> ARE YOU AND
SENATOR SCHUMER --
>> President Trump: WE ARE
DISCUSSING THAT.
WE ARE DISCUSSING MANY THINGS.
>> ARE YOU ON THE SAME PAGE
[BUZZER]
>> President Trump: WE ARE NOT
SO FAR AWAY.
>> AND TWO DR. FAUCI, IF I
COULD.
THERE HAS BEEN SOME PROBLEMS
WITH HYDROXY CRITICALLY.
IS THERE ANY EVIDENCE TO SUGGEST
THAT AS WITH MALARIA, IT MIGHT
BE USED WITH COVID-19 QUESTION
MIKE >> THE ANSWER IS NO, AND
THE EVIDENCE THAT THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT IS ANECDOTAL
EVIDENCE.
SO AS A COMMISSIONER OF THE FDA
AND THE PRESIDENT ANNOUNCED
YESTERDAY, WE ARE TRYING TO
STRIKE A BALANCE BETWEEN MAKING
SOMETHING THAT HAS THE POTENTIAL
OF AN EFFECT IT TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AVAILABLE.
AT THE SAME TIME, WE DO IT UNDER
THE PROTOCOL THAT WOULD GIVE US
INFORMATION TO DETERMINE IF IT
IS TRULY SAFE AND TRULY
EFFECTIVE.
BUT THE INFORMATION THAT YOU ARE
REFERRING TO SPECIFICALLY IS
ANECDOTAL.
IT WAS NOT DONE IN A CONTROLLED
CLINICAL TRIAL, SO YOU REALLY
CAN'T MAKE ANY DEFINITIVE
STATEMENT ABOUT IT.
>> PRESIDENT --
>> President Trump: I THINK
WITHOUT SAYING TOO MUCH, I AM
PROBABLY MORE OF A FAN OF THAT,
MAYBE THEN ANYBODY.
BUT I AM A BIG FAN.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
WE ALL UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
DOCTOR SAID IS 100% CORRECT.
IT'S EARLY.
YOU KNOW, I'VE SEEN THINGS THAT
ARE IMPRESSIVE.
WE WILL SEE.
WE'RE GOING TO KNOW SOON.
INCLUDING SAFETY.
BUT WHEN YOU GET TO SAFETY, THIS
HAS BEEN PRESCRIBED FOR MANY
YEARS FOR PEOPLE TO COMBAT
MALARIA, WHICH IS A BIG PROBLEM.
AND IT IS VERY EFFECTIVE.
IT IS A STRONG DRUG.
SO WE WILL SEE.
AS I UNDERSTAND, IS NOT A
CORRECT STATEMENT?
IT WAS FAIRLY EFFECTIVE ON SARS.
>> YOU HAVE TO BE CAREFUL WHEN
YOU SAY FAIRLY EFFECTIVE.
IT WAS NEVER DONE IN A CLINICAL
TRIAL.
IT WAS GIVEN TO INDIVIDUALS WHO
FELT THAT MAYBE IT WORKED.
THAT'S THE POINT.
WHENEVER YOU DO A CLINICAL
TRIAL, YOU DO STANDARD OF CARE
VERSUS STANDARD OF CARE, VERSUS
WHAT YOU ARE EVALUATING.
THAT IS THE REASON WHY WE SHOWED
IN A BULLOCK, PARTICULAR
INTERVENTIONS WORK.
>> WITH ALL THE POSSIBLE
THERAPIES, YESTERDAY,
MR. PRESIDENT, YOU SAID THAT
THEY WERE FOR IMMEDIATE
DELIVERY.
>> President Trump: WE ARE
ORDERING THEM.
MILLIONS OF UNITS ARE ORDERED.
ONE OF THE COMPANIES, AS YOU
KNOW.
A VERY BIG GREAT COMPANY.
MILLIONS OF UNITS ARE ORDERED.
AND WE ARE GOING TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
WE ARE GOING TO BE TALKING TO
THE GOVERNORS ABOUT IT.
AND OF THE FDA IS WORKING ON IT
RIGHT NOW.
THE ADVANTAGE IS THAT IT HAS
BEEN PRESCRIBED FOR TOTALLY
DIFFERENT PROBLEMS, BUT IT HAS
BEEN PRESCRIBED FOR MANY YEARS,
AND EVERYONE KNOWS THE LEVELS
OF -- THE NEGATIVES AND THE
POSITIVES, BUT I WILL SAY THAT I
AM A MAN THAT COMES FROM A VERY
POSITIVE SCHOOL WHEN IT COMES TO
LOVE PARTICULAR ONE OF THESE
DRUGS.
AND WE WILL SEE HOW IT WORKS
OUT.
I AM NOT SAYING IT WILL, BUT
PEOPLE MAY BE SURPRISED.
BY THE WAY, THAT WOULD BE A
GAME CHANGER.
WE ARE GOING TO KNOW VERY SOON,
BUT WE HAVE ORDERED MILLIONS OF
UNITS.
IT'S BEING ORDERED FROM BAYER.
THERE ARE ANOTHER COUPLE OF
COMPANIES THAT DO IT.
>> THEY SAY THAT THERE IS NO
MAGIC DRUG FOR CORONAVIRUS RIGHT
NOW.
>> President Trump: I
DISAGREE.
MAYBE AND MAYBE NOT.
MAYBE THERE IS.
MAYBE THERE ISN'T.
WE WE HAVE TO SEE.
>> IS IT POSSIBLE THAT YOUR
IMPULSE TO PUT A POSITIVE SPIN
ON THINGS MAY BE GIVING
AMERICANS A FALSE SENSE --
>> President Trump: NOW, I
DON'T THINK SO.
NO, I DON'T THINK SO.
>> NOT YET APPROVED DRUG --
>> President Trump: SUCH A
LOVELY QUESTION.
IT MAY WORK, AND IT MAY NOT.
I AGREE WITH THE DOCTOR WHEN HE
SAYS IT MAY WORK.
IT MAY NOT WORK.
I FEEL GOOD ABOUT IT.
THAT'S ALL IT IS.
JUST A FEELING.
I'M A SMART GUY.
I FEEL GOOD ABOUT IT.
WE WILL SEE.
WE WILL SEE SOON ENOUGH.
AND WE CERTAINLY HAVE SOME VERY
BIG SAMPLES OF PEOPLE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE PEOPLE, THERE
ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT ARE IN
BIG TROUBLE.
AND THIS IS NOT A DRUG THAT
OBVIOUSLY I THINK I CAN SPEAK
FROM A LOT OF EXPERIENCE BECAUSE
IT HAS BEEN OUT THERE FOR OVER
20 YEARS.
SO IT IS NOT A DRUG THAT YOU
HAVE A HUGE AMOUNT OF DANGER
WITH.
IT IS NOT LIKE A BRAND-NEW TRUCK
THAT HAS BEEN JUST CREATED THAT
MAY HAVE AN UNBELIEVABLE,
MONUMENTAL EFFECT LIKE KILL YOU.
WE ARE GOING TO KNOW VERY SOON.
AND I CAN TELL YOU, THE FDA IS
WORKING VERY HARD TO GET IT OUT.
RIGHT NOW, IN TERMS OF MALARIA,
IF YOU WANTED, YOU CAN HAVE A
PRESCRIPTION.
IT'S VERY EFFECTIVE.
IT WORKS.
AND I AM NOT BEING OVERLY
OPTIMISTIC OR PESSIMISTIC.
I SURE AS HELL THINK WE HAVE TO
GIVE IT A TRY.
LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
WE HAVE NOTHING TO LOSE.
YOU KNOW THE EXPRESSION.
WHAT THE HELL DO YOU HAVE TO
LOSE?
>> WHAT DO YOU SAY TO AMERICANS
WHO ARE SCARED?
14,000 WHO ARE SICK, MILLIONS,
AS A WITNESS, WHO ARE SCARED
RIGHT NOW APPEARED WHAT YOU SAY
TO AMERICANS WHO ARE WATCHING
RIGHT NOW WHO ARE SCARED?
>> President Trump: WHAT I SAY
THAT YOU ARE A TERRIBLE
REPORTER.
THAT'S WHAT I SAY.
I THINK THAT'S A VERY NASTY
QUESTION, AND I THINK IT'S A
VERY BAD SIGNAL THAT YOU'RE
PUTTING OUT TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE LOOKING
FOR ANSWERS, AND THEY ARE
LOOKING FOR HOPE.
YOU ARE DOING SENSATIONALISM.
AT THE SAME WITH NBC AND
COMCAST.
I DON'T CALL IT COMCAST.
LET ME ASK FOR WHOM YOU WORK.
LET ME SAY SOMETHING.
THAT'S REALLY BAD REPORTING.
AND YOU OUGHT TO GET BACK TO
REPORTING INSTEAD OF
SENSATIONALISM.
LET'S SEE IF IT WORKS.
IT MIGHT, AND IT MIGHT NOT.
I HAPPEN TO FEEL GOOD ABOUT IT,
BUT WHO KNOWS?
I'VE BEEN RIGHT A LOT.
LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
JOHN.
YOU OUGHT TO BE ASHAMED OF
YOURSELF.
>> ARE THEY FOR CLINICAL TRIALS
OR DISTRIBUTION TO THE PATIENT
POPULATION?
>> President Trump: WE ARE
GOING TO BE TAKING SAMPLES.
GOVERNOR CUOMO IS VERY MUCH
INTERESTED IN THIS DRUG.
THEY ARE GOING TO WORK ON IT
ALSO AFTER THEY GET APPROVAL.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
BUT WE WILL USE IT ON PEOPLE.
THAT ARE NOT DOING GREAT.
OR EVEN AT THE BEGINNING OF NOT
FEELING WELL.
AND JOHN, WHAT DO WE HAVE TO
LOSE?
IT'S BEEN OUT THERE FOR SO LONG.
WE HEAR GOOD THINGS.
LET'S SEE.
MAYBE IT WORKS, AND MAYBE A
DOZEN.
>> I UNDERSTAND ALL THAT.
ACCESS --
>> President Trump: WE ARE
DOING THAT, I GUESS.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK WITH
DR. FAUCI.
FOLLOW UP ON WHAT THE
PRESIDENT IS SAYING.
IT SHOULD AMERICANS HAVE HOPE IN
THIS DRUG RIGHT NOW?
I WOULD LIKE TO FOLLOW-UP ON
PETER'S QUESTION.
COULD YOU PLEASE ISSUE AN
ADDRESS TO AMERICANS WHO ARE
SCARED RIGHT NOW.
>> President Trump: THERE
REALLY ISN'T THAT MUCH OF A
DIFFERENCE.
THE PRESIDENT FEELS OPTIMISTIC
ABOUT SOMETHING, HIS FEELING
ABOUT IT.
WHAT I AM SAYING IS THAT IT
MIGHT BE EFFECTIVE.
I'M NOT SAYING THAT IT ISN'T.
IT MIGHT BE EFFECTIVE, BUT AS A
SCIENTIST, AS WE ARE GETTING IT
OUT THERE, YOU NEED TO DO IT IN
NO WAY, WHILE WE ARE MAKING IT
AVAILABLE FOR PEOPLE WHO MIGHT
WANT TO HOPE THAT IT MIGHT WORK.
YOU ARE ALSO COLLECTING DATA
THAT WILL ULTIMATELY SHOW THAT
IT IS TRULY EFFECTIVE AND SAFE
UNDER THE CONDITIONS OF
COVID-19.
SO IT IS JUST A QUESTION OF HOW
ONE FEELS ABOUT IT.
>> IS THERE ANY REASON TO
BELIEVE IT'S NOT SAFE?
>> CERTAINLY HAS A DRUG, ANY
DRUG, JOHN, AS SOME TOXICITIES.
THE DECADES OF EXPERIENCE THAT
WE HAVE WITH THIS DRUG INDICATE
THAT THE TOXICITIES ARE RARE,
AND IN MANY RESPECTS, ARE
REVERSIBLE.
WHAT WE DON'T KNOW IS WHEN YOU
PUT IT IN THE CONTEXT OF ANOTHER
DISEASE.
WHETHER IT IS SAFE.
FUNDAMENTALLY, I THINK IT
PROBABLY IS GOING TO BE SAFE.
BUT I LIKE TO PROVE THINGS
FIRST.
SO IT REALLY IS A QUESTION OF
NOT A LOT OF DIFFERENCE.
IT IS THE HOPE THAT IT WILL WORK
VERSUS PROVING THAT IT WORKS.
SO I DON'T SEE A BIG DIFFERENCE.
>> President Trump: I AGREE.
>> PEOPLE AT HOME WHO HAVE THEIR
CHILDREN'S IN THEIR HOMES, HOME
SCHOOLING, THEY DON'T HAVE THE
MASKS THEY NEED TO DO THEIR
JOBS.
YOUR MESSAGE TO THEM?
>> President Trump: MY MESSAGE
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE IS THAT
THERE IS A VERY LOW INCIDENCE OF
DEATH.
YOU UNDERSTAND THAT.
AND WE ARE GOING TO COME THROUGH
THIS STRONGER THAN EVER BEFORE.
IF YOU GET IT, IF YOU HAPPEN TO
GET IT, IT IS HIGHLY UNLIKELY --
IT IS LOOKING LIKE IT IS GETTING
TO A NUMBER THAT IS MUCH SMALLER
THAN PEOPLE ORIGINALLY THOUGHT
IN TERMS OF THE ULTIMATE -- THE
ULTIMATE PROBLEM, WHICH WOULD BE
DEATH.
MY MESSAGE TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AS NUMBER ONE, YOU'VE
DONE AN INCREDIBLE JOB.
AND CREDIBLE.
WHAT YOU'VE GONE THROUGH HAS
BEEN INCREDIBLE.
IT WASN'T THEIR FAULT.
IT WASN'T THE FAULT OF 140 OTHER
COUNTRIES WHERE THIS HAS
HAPPENED.
AND THERE IS TREMENDOUS HOPE.
I THINK WE ARE GOING TO COME OUT
STRONGER, BETTER, BIGGER.
IN EVERY WAY, I THINK WE ARE
GOING TO BE A BETTER COUNTRY
THAN WE WERE BEFORE.
WE LEARNED A LOT.
WHO TO RELY ON, WHO NOT TO RELY
ON.
BUT OUR COUNTRY, OUR COUNTRY HAS
BEEN INCREDIBLE.
THE WAY THAT THEY PULL TOGETHER.
INCLUDING THE FACT THAT I JUST
SPOKE TO SENATOR SCHUMER.
WE HAD A WONDERFUL CONVERSATION.
WE BOTH WANT TO GET TO A
SOLUTION.
BUT IT HAS BEEN -- REALLY FOR
ME, WATCHING AND SEEING PEOPLE
THAT WEREN'T SPEAKING, GETTING
ALONG WELL.
BECAUSE WE ALL HAVE ONE COMMON
AIM.
THAT IS TO GET RID OF THIS
INVISIBLE ENEMY, GET RID OF IT
FAST, AND THEN GO BACK TO THE
KIND OF ECONOMY THAT WE HAD.
AND MAYBE EVEN BETTER.
YEAH, PLEASE.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, A FEW
QUESTIONS.
THE FIRST QUESTION -- MANY SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE CONCERNED,
WORRIED ABOUT HOW LONG IT WILL
TAKE --
>> President Trump: WE ARE
GOING TO BE HELPING THEM A LOT.
INCLUDING MY CONVERSATION WITH
MITCH AND WITH CHUCK.
A BIG FOCUS OF THAT CONVERSATION
WAS SMALL BUSINESSES.
BECAUSE THEY ARE REALLY THE
ENGINE BEHIND OUR COUNTRY.
MORE SO THAN THE BIG ONES.
THEY ARE THE ENGINES BEHIND OUR
COUNTRY.
>> ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS THAT MAY
HAVE USED INFORMATION TO SELL
STOCKS?
>> President Trump: I SAW SOME
NAMES.
I KNOW ALL OF THEM.
I KNOW EVERYONE MENTIONED.
DIANNE FEINSTEIN, I GUESS.
AND A COUPLE OF OTHERS.
I DON'T KNOW TOO MUCH ABOUT WHAT
IT'S ABOUT, BUT I FIND THEM TO
ALL BE VERY HONORABLE PEOPLE.
AND THEY SAID THEY DID NOTHING
WRONG.
I FIND THEM -- THE WHOLE GROUP,
VERY HONORABLE PEOPLE.
>> SO, THE WHOLE GROUP WOULD
INCLUDE RICHARD BURR, THE HEAD
OF THE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
IT ALSO WOULD INCLUDE A
SENATOR TELE LOEFFLER.
THE QUESTION IS WHETHER THEY
SHOULD BE INVESTIGATED FOR THAT.
>> President Trump: IT ALSO
INCLUDES
SENATOR DIANNE FEINSTEIN,
DEMOCRAT.
WHY DIDN'T YOU MENTION HER NAME?
AND I THINK SHE'S A VERY
INTERESTING PERSON IT'S
INTERESTING THAT YOU MENTION TWO
NAMES, BUT NOT WHEN THAT HAPPENS
TO BE A DEMOCRAT.
>> ANY SENATORS?
>> President Trump: I DON'T
KNOW.
BUT I FIND THEM TO BE HONORABLE
PEOPLE.
>> YOU COMPARED YOURSELF -- YOU
SEE YOURSELF AS A WARTIME
PRESIDENT RIGHT NOW, LEADING THE
COUNTRY THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC
THAT WE ARE EXPERIENCING.
DO YOU THINK'S GOING OFF ON
PETER, GOING OFF ON A NETWORK IS
APPROPRIATE?
>> President Trump: I DO
BECAUSE I THINK PETER IS -- YOU
KNOW, I HAVE DEALT WITH PETER
FOR A LONG TIME.
AND I THINK PETER IS NOT A GOOD
JOURNALIST WHEN IT COMES TO
FAIRNESS.
>> HE WAS ASKING ABOUT YOUR
MESSAGE TO THE COUNTRY APPEARS
TO BE SIX THE COUNTRY HAS TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS
INDEED -- WHETHER WE LIKE IT OR
NOT, THAT THERE IS A LOT OF
REALLY GREAT NEWS AND GREAT
JOURNALISM.
AND THERE'S A LOT OF FAKE NEWS
OUT THERE.
AND I HEAR IT ALL, AND I SEE IT
ALL, AND I UNDERSTAND IT ALL
BECAUSE I'M IN THE MIDST OF IT.
SO WHEN SOMEBODY WRITES A STORY,
WHEN THERE IS A STORY ON
TELEVISION, AND I KNOW IT'S
FALSE, AND THEY SAY THEY HAVE 15
SOURCES HAVE SAID -- AND I KNOW
THERE'S NO SOURCES.
THERE IS NO SOURCES.
THEY ARE JUST MAKING IT UP.
AND I CALLED PETER OUT.
I CALL OTHER PEOPLE OUT TOO.
THIS IS A TIME TO COME TOGETHER.
BUT COMING TOGETHER IS MUCH
HARDER WHEN WE HAVE DISHONEST
JOURNALIST.
IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT PROFESSION
THAT YOU'RE IN.
IT'S A PROFESSION THAT I THINK
IS INCREDIBLE.
I CHERISH IT.
BUT WHEN PEOPLE ARE DISHONEST,
THEY REALLY DO HURT OUR COUNTRY.
YEAH, IN THE BACK.
>> CHINA HAS BEEN IN
COMMUNICATION WITH THE
UNITED STATES.
HOPEFUL THAT WE WILL KNOW MORE
ABOUT CORONAVIRUS.
TWO TRAVELERS FROM CHINA ON
FEBRUARY 2ND, THEY HAVE BEEN IN
LOCKDOWN SINCE JANUARY 24TH.
AND THIS ALL HAPPENED ALMOST TWO
MONTHS AGO.
IF YOU COULD HAVE KNOWN EARLIER,
AND ALSO YOU HAS BEEN CALLING
CORONAVIRUS --
>> President Trump: I CAN SAY
FOR MYSELF, I HAVE A VERY GOOD
RELATIONSHIP WITH CHINA AND WITH
PRESIDENT XI.
I HAVE GREAT RESPECT FOR
I CONSIDER HIM TO BE A FRIEND OF
MINE.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT THIS GOT
OUT OF CONTROL.
IT CAME FROM CHINA.
IT GOT OUT OF CONTROL.
SOME PEOPLE ARE UPSET, I KNOW.
I KNOW PRESIDENT XI.
HE LOVES CHINA.
HE RESPECTS THE UNITED STATES.
AND I HAVE TO SAY, I RESPECT
CHINA GREATLY, AND I RESPECT
PRESIDENT XI.
>> CALLING THE CORONAVIRUS --
>> IS IT A DEAL BREAKER FOR
YOU --
>> President Trump: I NEVER
LIKED AT STOCK BUYBACKS.
WHEN WE DID A BIG TAX CUT, AND
WHEN THEY TOOK THE MONEY AND DID
BUYBACKS, THAT IS NOT BUILDING A
HANGER.
THAT IS NOT BUYING AN AIRCRAFT.
THAT IS NOT DOING THAT KIND OF
THINGS THAT I WANT THEM TO DO.
AND WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT
BUYBACKS.
WE DIDN'T THINK THAT WE WOULD
HAVE HAD TO RESTRICT IT BECAUSE
WE THOUGHT THAT THEY WOULD HAVE
KNOWN BETTER.
BUT THEY DIDN'T KNOW BETTER.
NOT IN ALL CASES, OBVIOUSLY.
SOME PEOPLE DID AN INCREDIBLE
JOB.
YOU SEE WHAT'S HAPPENS.
UNTIL THIS INVISIBLE ENEMY
APPEARED, WE NEVER HAD AN
ECONOMY LIKE THIS.
BUT THERE WERE SOME COMPANIES
THAT USED IT TO BUY BACK STOCK,
DRIVING UP THE PRICE OF THE
STOCK IN MANY CASES.
AND AS FAR AS WHETHER OR NOT WE
WILL KEEP THEM IN BUSINESS
BECAUSE OF THE WORKERS, FRANKLY
FOR THE MOST PART BECAUSE OF THE
WORKERS.
THE WORKERS ARE MY NUMBER ONE
CONCERN, BUT THE WAY WE TAKE
CARE OF THE WORKERS AS WE HAVE
TO KEEP THE COMPANY'S GOING.
I AM FINE WITH RESTRICTING
BUYBACKS.
I WOULD DEMAND THAT THERE BEING
NO STOCK BUYBACKS.
I DON'T WANT THEM TAKING
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
AND BUYING BACK THEIR STOCK
BECAUSE THAT DOES NOTHING.
>> I HAVE ANOTHER ONE FOR
DR. FAUCI AND ONE FOR YOU.
>> President Trump: SECRETARY
ESTATE MIKE POMPEO IS EXTREMELY
BUSY.
YOU KNOW WHAT I LIKE TO DO?
I LIKE HIM TO GO BACK TO THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
OR AS I CALL IT, THE DEEP
STATE DEPARTMENT, IF YOU DON'T
MIND.
I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE HIM GO BACK
AND DO HIS JOB.
SO DOES ANYBODY HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS --
YEAH, HOW ABOUT YOU?
ONLY FOR THE SECRETARY.
>> ON WORK TRAVEL, CAN YOU
DEFINE THAT?
ANYONE ACROSS THE BORDER?
CAN YOU DEFINE A LITTLE BIT THE
MEASURES YOU HAVE TAKEN?
>> GREAT QUESTION.
WE ARE CONCERNED IN PARTICULAR
ABOUT AGRICULTURE WORKERS THAT
NEED TO GET ACROSS.
WE ARE GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO KEEP
THAT WORKING BETWEEN OUR TWO
COUNTRIES.
DHS AND THE STATE DEPARTMENT
WILL WORK TOGETHER.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE KEEP
COMMERCE BETWEEN CANADA, THE
UNITED STATES, AND MEXICO
PREPARED FOR THE DAY THAT THE
ECONOMY BOUNCES BACK LIKE WE
EXPECT IT WILL.
>> MR. SECRETARY, THE MEXICAN
GOVERNMENT HAS NOT ANNOUNCED ANY
TRAVEL BAN ON THE EURO.
YOU HAVE BEEN IN TALKS WITH THEM
ON WHEN THEY ARE GOING TO DO
THIS.
AND THEN A SECOND QUESTION, THEY
ALSO ARE TELLING US -- THEY SAID
IN THE PRESS CONFERENCE THAT
THEY WILL NOT TAKE BACK ANY
NONMEXICAN CITIZEN.
ANY OTHER THIRD PARTIES, WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT WILL HAPPEN TO
THEM.
SO CAN YOU ADDRESS WHAT WILL
HAPPEN TO THOSE IMMIGRANTS THAT
YOU ARE SAYING WILL NOT BE
ALLOWED TO ENTER THE U.S., AND
MEXICO IS SAYING THAT THEY WILL
NOT BE ALLOWED TO STAY IN MEXICO
EITHER?
>> I WILL SAY THE FIRST ONE, AND
THEN GIVE YOU THE SECOND ONE.
WITH RESPECT TO TRAVEL, I SPOKE
WITH HIM A FEW TIMES ABOUT THIS.
I'M VERY CONFIDENT WE ARE GOING
TO GET TO A REALLY GOOD PLACE
THAT PROTECTS THE MEXICAN PEOPLE
IN THE AMERICAN PEOPLE FROM
THOSE WHO MAY BE TRAVELING WHERE
WE HAVE DESIGNATIONS.
SO THAT THEY ARE NOT COMING INTO
MEXICO AND THEN COMING INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
I'M VERY CONFIDENT WE WILL DO
THAT, AND WE WILL MAKE THAT
ANNOUNCEMENT SHORTLY TOGETHER.
>> AS WE IMPLEMENT THE CDC'S
ORDER, WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS THAT CROSS
THE BORDER ILLEGALLY AND
REPATRIATE SOME, MOVE THEM
QUICKLY BACK TO THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE AND ANY OTHER COUNTRY.
WE ARE GOING TO DO THAT IN A
RAPID FASHION APPEARED WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH MEXICO TO
MAKE SURE THAT MEXICAN NATIONALS
GO BACK, AS WELL AS OTHER
POPULATIONS.
>> WHAT WOULD YOU DO WITH THOSE
COUNTRIES THAT ARE NOT MEXICO?
>> WE ARE DOING ALL OF THE
ABOVE.
STUNNING INDIVIDUALS BACK TO
MEXICO, BACK TO NORTHERN
TRIANGLE COUNTRIES.
CUBA, HAITI.
122 DIFFERENT NATIONS THAT WE
SEE.
I COME ACROSS THE BORDER.
WE WILL BE SENDING THEM BACK
INDIVIDUALLY TO THEIR COUNTRIES,
BUT ALSO WORKING WITH MEXICO TO
SEND ADDITIONAL POPULATIONS BACK
THERE AS WELL.
>> President Trump: WHAT YOU
SENT, BEFORE USE OF THE
NONMEXICANS GOING TO MEXICO --
WE ARE NOT SENDING THEM TO
MEXICO.
WE ARE SENDING THAT BACK TO
THEIR OWN COUNTRY.
WHY WOULD MEXICO TAKE PEOPLE
THAT AREN'T FROM MEXICO?
WE ARE SENDING THEM BACK -- IN
THE CASE OF GUATEMALA, HONDURAS,
EL SALVADOR.
A LOT OF OTHER COUNTRIES.
THEY GO BACK TO THE COUNTRIES
FROM WHERE THEY CAME.
AND PLEASE --
>> SECRETARY POMPEO, IS THERE
ANY PARTICULAR --
>> WE CERTAINLY HAVE SEEN IT
COME FROM PLACES LIKE CHINA AND
RUSSIA AND IRAN.
WITH OUR COORDINATED EFFORTS TO
DISPARAGE WHAT AMERICA IS DOING.
IT DOING ALL THE THINGS THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS SET IN
MOTION HERE.
>> OTHER THAN WHAT YOU'RE DOING
THIS MORNING, WHAT ARE YOU DOING
TO FIGHT BACK?
>> A LOT OF THINGS.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
AMERICANS GO TO TRUSTED SOURCES
FOR INFORMATION.
THEY NEED TO KNOCK IT OFF.
WE DON'T APPROVE OF IT.
AND THERE ARE A HANDFUL OF OTHER
THINGS TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
RIGHT INFORMATION IS OUT THERE.
ACCURATE INFORMATION IS GIVEN.
THIS IDEA OF TRANSPARENCY IS
VERY IMPORTANT.
HOW WE PROTECT AMERICAN PEOPLE
FROM SOMETHING LIKE THIS EVER
HAPPENING AGAIN.
>> YOU WANT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
TO BE COMING TO TRUSTED SOURCES
OF INFORMATION.
DOES IT UNDERMINE YOU WHEN THE
PRESIDENT STANDS UP THERE AND
CALLS US ON TRUSTWORTHY?
>> I'M NOT ANSWERING THAT
QUESTION.
>> President Trump: PLEASE.
>> IN TERMS OF AMERICANS WHO
FIND THEMSELVES NO LONGER ABLE
TO FLY BACK TO THE
UNITED STATES, WHAT EFFORTS ARE
BEING MADE TO HELP THEM?
>> I APPRECIATE THAT QUESTION.
WE HAVE HAD THE FIRST TO GO OR
MAYBE THREE FLIGHTS OUT OF
MOROCCO.
WE ARE GOING TO WORK TO GET
PEOPLE BACK.
WE ARE URGING INDIVIDUALS WHEN
THEY CAN'T GET BACK ON THEIR
OWN, THEY OUGHT TO TRY TO DO
THAT.
BUT WE HAVE A TEAM SET UP AT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT, THE
REPATRIATION TALK FOR THAT IS
WORKING WITH EACH OF THESE
INSTANCES.
WE HAVE HEARD FROM INDIVIDUALS,
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, TRYING TO
GET THEM BACK WHERE AIR TRAVEL
HAS BEEN DISRUPTED.
WE WILL GET THAT DONE OVER TIME.
WE WILL GET IT DONE
SUCCESSFULLY.
>> IS THERE ANY SENSE OF JUST
HOW BIG THE PROBLEM IS?
>> WE DON'T KNOW THE FULL SCALE
OF IT, BUT WE THINK WE HAVE THE
LARGEST NUMBER IDENTIFIED.
THOSE WHO ARE WATCHING THAT ARE
SOMEPLACE, YOU CAN GO ON THE
STATE DEPARTMENT WEBSITE.
YOU CAN LOGIN, AND WE WILL TRACK
YOU, AND TRY TO GET EVERYBODY
BACK AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
>> HOW LONG ARE THESE BORDER
RESTRICTIONS LIKELY TO LAST?
>> THEY WILL LAST AS LONG AS WE
NEED TO DO IT TO PROTECT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW LONG.
>> HAVE YOU DETERMINE WHETHER
IRAN IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT
ATTACK LAST WEEK?
>> President Trump: MAYBE WE
SHOULDN'T SAY.
>> LET ME JUST GET BACK TO YOU
ON THE ANSWER TO THAT.
WHAT WE CAN SAY WITH CERTAINTY
IS THIS.
WE HAVE MADE CLEAR ALL ALONG
THAT THE IRAQ HE SHIITE MILITIAS
ARE -- WE HAVE URGED THE
IRANIANS NOT TO DO THAT.
WE HAVE SAID THAT THEY WILL BE
HELD RESPONSIBLE FOR THOSE
ATTACKS WHEN THEY THREATEN
AMERICAN LIVES.
>> PEACE CORPS VOLUNTEERS THAT
ARE IN 60 PLUS COUNTRIES, HOW
THEY ALL BEEN RETURNED?
>> I DON'T KNOW IF THEY ARE ALL
BACK OR NOT.
I KNOW THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
DIRECTED.
I COULDN'T TELL YOU IF WE HAVE
ALL OF THEM BACK AT.
>> TO GET BACK TO THE TROOPS IN
IRAQ AND AFGHANISTAN, CAN YOU
GIVE US THE STATUS ON THEM?
>> I KNOW WE HAVE STATE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIALS TOO.
OUR TEAM.
WE HAVE HAD SIGNIFICANT SUCCESS
ON THAT TO DATE.
THERE ARE A FEW PLACES WE HAVE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO GET TO.
WE WILL GET THEM THERE APPEARED
>> HOW EXACTLY ARE YOU GOING TO
GET THOSE AMERICANS BACK, AND DO
YOU HAVE ANY PLANS TO GET THE
MILITARY INVOLVED?
>> THESE FIRST EFFORTS ARE
COMBINE COMMERCIAL PRIVATE
FLIGHTS I WILL PLAN, BRING THEM
BACK TO YOU DESTINATION HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES.
WE WILL DO THAT.
TRAVEL BACK OTHER WAYS AS WELL.
WE HAVE WORKED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE TO SAVE WE
WILL BRING THEM BACK ON THOSE
FLIGHTS AS WELL.
IT IS A WHOLE GOVERNMENT EFFORT
TO BRING THEM BACK.
THEY ARE GOING TO HELP US IN ANY
WAY THAT THEY CAN.
>> A QUESTION ON IRAN AGAIN.
[INDISTINCT QUESTION]
>> THE WHOLE WORLD SHOULD KNOW
THAT HUMANITARIAN ASSISTANCE
INTO IRAN IS WIDE OPEN.
IT IS NOT SANCTIONED.
WE HAVE OFFERED TO PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE TO THE IRANIANS AS
WELL.
I HAVE TALKED WITH THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION ABOUT THIS.
WE ARE DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO FACILITATE BOTH THE
HUMANITARIAN ASSISTANCE MOVING
IN AND TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
FINANCIAL TRANSACTIONS CAN TAKE
PLACE AFTER THAT.
THERE IS NO SANCTIONS ON
MEDICINES GOING TO IRAN.
NO SANCTIONS ON HUMANITARIAN
ASSISTANCE.
THEY'VE GOT A TERRIBLE PROBLEM
THERE, AND WE WANT THAT
HUMANITARIAN MEDICARE ASSISTANCE
TO GET TO THEM.
WE ARE WORKING TO DO ALL THE
THINGS WE HAVE HAD IN PLACE FOR
THE FIRST THREE YEARS HERE TO
DELIVER SECURITY FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> President Trump: THEY KNOW
THE ANSWER.
THEY KNOW THE ANSWER.
THE LEADERS.
THEY KNOW THE ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION.
>> TIME WHEN THOUSANDS ARE
WORKING VERY HARD AROUND THE
WORLD TO COME BY --
>> I'VE WORKED WITH THE
PRESIDENT FOR THREE YEARS NOW.
I KNOW HOW MUCH HE VALUES THE
PEOPLE ON OUR TEAM.
I HAVE KNOWN, AND I KNOW THAT HE
WATCHES OUR TEAM, TO PUSH BACK
AGAINST THIS VIRUS, TO KIM
AMERICA SAFE.
I KNOW HOW MUCH HE VALUES IT.
>> President Trump: WHAT A
GOOD ANSWER.
VERY TRUE TOO.
>> I APOLOGIZE.
>> President Trump: PLEASE, GO
AHEAD.
>> SECRETARY POMPEO, THE CDC
PICKED UP THAT THERE WAS SOME
SORT OF VIRUS HAPPENING IN WUHAN
AS EARLY AS DECEMBER.
WHEN DID THE CDC START LETTING
OTHER AGENCIES NOW THAT THERE
WAS SOMETHING IN CHINA
HAPPENING, AND THEN WHEN DID THE
WHOLE GOVERNMENT APPROACH START
TO HAPPEN?
>> SO, I WILL LET THEM --
>> DOCTOR, PLEASE.
>> SO, WE WERE ALERTED BY SOME
DISCUSSIONS THAT THE DIRECTOR OF
THE CDC HAD WITH CHINESE
COLLEAGUES ON JANUARY 3RD.
IT HAS SINCE BEEN KNOWN THAT
THERE MAY HAVE BEEN CASES IN
DECEMBER.
NOT THAT WE WERE ALERTED IN
>> ANOTHER QUESTION I HAVE FOR
YOU -- GO EXCUSE ME.
>> LET ME JUST SAY ONE MORE
THING.
THERE HAS BEEN SOME DISCUSSION
ABOUT CHINA.
WHAT THEY KNEW AND WHEN THEY
KNEW IT.
I HAVE BEEN VERY CRITICAL.
WE NEED TO KNOW IMMEDIATELY.
THE WORLD IS ENTITLED TO NOW.
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT WAS THAT
FIRST YOU KNOW OF THIS RISK TO
THE WORLD.
AND THAT PUTS A SPECIAL
OBLIGATION, TO MAKE SURE.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT RETRIBUTION.
THIS MATTERS GOING FORWARD.
WE ARE IN A LIVE EXERCISE NOW TO
GET THIS RIGHT.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT EVEN
TODAY, THE DATASETS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO EVERY COUNTRY,
INCLUDING DATA SETS AVAILABLE TO
THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY ARE
MADE AVAILABLE TO THE WHOLE
WORLD.
IT IS IMPERATIVE TO KEEP PEOPLE
SAFE.
WE TALK ABOUT THE ABSENCE OF
DATA, NOT BEING ABLE TO MAKE
JUDGMENTS ABOUT WHAT TO DO.
THIS TRANSPARENCY, THIS
REAL-TIME INFORMATION SHARING
ISN'T ABOUT POLITICAL GAINS OR
RETRIBUTION.
IT IS ABOUT KEEPING PEOPLE SAFE.
SO, WHEN YOU SEE A DELAY IN
INFORMATION FROM THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY TO THE PEOPLE
WHO WE WANTED TO GET INTO CHINA
IMMEDIATELY TO ASSIST IN THIS,
EVERY MOMENT OF THE LIFE TO BE
ABLE TO IDENTIFY THE RISK
FACTORS CREATES RISK FOR PEOPLE
ALL AROUND THE WORLD.
SO THIS IS WHY IT IS NOT ABOUT
BLAMING SOMEONE FOR THIS.
THIS IS ABOUT MOVING FORWARD TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE THE INFORMATION WE NEED TO
DO OUR JOBS.
>> MR. SECRETARY, WHAT MESSAGE
DO YOU THINK IT SENDS TO OTHER
COUNTRIES WHEN YOU HAVE THE
PRESENCE OF THE UNITED STATES
LASHING OUT AT REPORTERS?
>> I HAVE HAD MY FRUSTRATIONS
WITH REPORTERS TOO.
ALL I ASK IS THAT YOU LISTEN TO
WHAT WE SAY AND REPORTED
ACCURATELY.
IT'S FRUSTRATING.
IT'S ENORMOUSLY FRUSTRATING.
WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO TELL
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THE TRUTH,
AND THOSE WHO ARE REPORTING ON
WHAT WE ARE DOING HAVE AN EQUAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO REPORT
ACCURATELY.
>> WHAT MESSAGE DOES IT SEND TO
COUNTRIES --
>> I HAVE SEEN MANY THINGS ABOUT
THE STATE DEPARTMENT BE REPORTED
AT WILDLY AND ACCURATELY ON
MULTIPLE OCCASIONS.
I HAVE SPOKEN TO THOSE REPORTERS
EACH AND EVERY TIME.
AND I WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO.
>> MR. PRESIDENT,
SENATOR JOHNSON --
>> I THINK I HAVE WORN THEM OUT,
MR. PRESIDENT.
>> MR. SECRETARY,
SENATOR JOHNSON HAS SUGGESTED
THAT YOU AND THE ADMINISTRATION
MAY BE OVERREACTING.
HE SAYS WE DON'T SHUT DOWN OUR
ECONOMY BECAUSE 10,000 PEOPLE
DIE ON THE HIGHWAYS.
WE DON'T SHUT DOWN OUR OUR
ECONOMIES BECAUSE BECAUSE TENS
OF THOUSANDS PEOPLE DIE FROM THE
COMMON FLU.
AT WORST, 3.4% OF AMERICANS WILL
DIE FROM THIS VIRUS.
WHY DO YOU SAY TO PEOPLE THAT
HAVE THAT VIEW?
THAT
>> President Trump: I SAY THE
ENTIRE WORLD IS AGREEING WITH
US, THEY HAVE THEIR CHOICE.
EVERYONE IS DOING THE EXACT SAME
THING.
YOU CAN DO THAT, AND WE WILL SEE
WHAT HAPPENS IN TWO WEEKS, THREE
WEEKS.
IF WE CAN SAVE THOUSANDS OF
LIVES, AND EVEN MILLIONS OF
LIVES, YOU DON'T KNOW WHERE IT
GOES.
BUT YOU COULD BE TALKING ABOUT
MILLIONS OF LIVES.
YOU LOOK AT THE WORLD, THEY HAVE
SOME VERY SMART PEOPLE IN THE
WORLD, VERY SMART LEADERS IN THE
WORLD.
AND EVERYBODY IS DOING IT THE
WAY WE ARE DOING IT.
I THINK WE ARE DOING A BETTER
JOB THEN HOPEFULLY MOST, IF NOT
ALL.
A VERY EFFECTIVE JOB, BUT WE
WILL KNOW BETTER IN 14 OR 15
DAYS.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS AND MAYBE EVEN MORE
THEN THAT NUMBERS OF PEOPLE.
WE CAN BRING OUR FINANCES BACK
VERY QUICKLY.
WE CAN'T BRING THE PEOPLE BACK.
>> Reporter: MR. PRESIDENT, TO
FOLLOW UP ON THAT, THERE ARE
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE OUT THERE
THAT SHARE THAT YOU THAT SAY I
DON'T REALLY NEED TO SHUT THINGS
DOWN.
I DON'T REALLY NEED TO STAY AWAY
FROM STORES.
I CAN GO TO THE BEACH, AND THOSE
PEOPLE MAKING MULTIPLE ACTIONS
EXPONENTIALLY IS THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN LIFE AND DEATH.
>> President Trump: I AGREE
WITH THAT, BUT I WOULD LIKE
ANTHONY UT AND ANSWER THAT,
BECAUSE TO BE HONEST, THAT'S
WHAT HE DOES.
WE HAVE A LOT OF TALENTED PEOPLE
TELLING US WHAT THEY THINK WE
SHOULD DO.
>> THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT,
THAT IS A FALSE EQUIVALENCY TO
COMPARE TRAFFIC ACCIDENTS, THAT
IS TOTALLY OUT.
WE HAVE SOMETHING THAT IS NEW,
AND IT IS EMERGING.
AND YOU REALLY CAN'T UNDERSTAND
TOTALLY THE IMPACT THEY WILL
HAVE.
AND YOU TAKE A LOOK WHAT IS
GOING ON IN CHINA.
AND YOU SEE WHAT IS GOING ON
RIGHT NOW, RIGHT NOW IN ITALY
AND WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
NEW YORK CITY.
I DON'T THINK WHAT ANY MORAL
CONSCIENCE YOU CAN SAY, WHY
DON'T WE JUST LET IT RIP AND
HAPPEN AND LET X PERCENT OTHER
PEOPLE DIE, I DON'T UNDERSTAND
THE REASONING AT ALL.
>> President Trump: SO THE
SECRETARY OF STATE WILL BE
LEAVING, ANY OTHER QUESTIONS?
IN THE BACK.
EXCUSE ME, I DID NOT: YOU.
>> Reporter: THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT, TWO THINGS, THE
COUNT IS DOUBLING EVERY DAY,
THEY FEAR THAT THE SUPPLIES WILL
GO OUT OF THE WASTE.
YESTERDAY MAYOR de BLASIO SAID
CALL ON THE MILITARY FOR
SUPPLIES.
FOR THE STATE OF NEW YORK CITY
IN THE HANDS OF ONE MAN, HE HAS
A NEW YORKER, AND RIGHT NOW HE
IS BETRAYING WHERE HE COMES
FROM.
I PERSONALLY HAVE SPOKEN TO
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT NURSES WHO
SAY THAT THEY ARE BEING TOLD NOT
TO WEAR A MASK BECAUSE THE
SUPPLIES ARE SO LOW.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO THOSE BY
MAYOR de BLASIO?
>> President Trump: I AM NOT
DEALING WITH THE GOVERNOR.
AND THE GOVERNOR AGREES WITH ME.
AND I AGREE WITH HIM.
SO FAR WE HAVE BEEN VERY MUCH IN
SYNC.
I GUESS THEY ARE NOT AGREEING
WITH EACH OTHER, NECESSARILY.
BUT THE RELATIONSHIP WITH
NEW YORK.
I LOVE NEW YORK.
I GREW UP IN NEW YORK, AS YOU
KNOW.
THE RELATIONSHIP IS VERY GOOD.
AND I THINK GOVERNMENT AND THE
GOVERNOR HAVE BEEN GETTING ALONG
INCREDIBLY WELL WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
OKAY.
>> Reporter: A QUESTION FOR
SECRETARY WOLF IF I COULD.
ON ILLEGAL ENTRIES, PEOPLE WHO
ARE OTM, HOW WILL YOU TURN THAT
PROCESS AND TAKEN TO A COMMON
AREA AND THEN PUT BACK ON A
PLANE, SENT BACK, HOW WOULD THAT
PROCESS WORK?
>> AGAIN, IT IS A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS.
WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO DO IS
LIMIT THE AMOUNT OF CONTACT TO
THAT WE HAVE WITH THESE
INDIVIDUALS, NOT PUTTING THEM IN
BORDER PATROL FACILITIES, AND
THE LIKE.
IT WILL BE VERY RAPID.
WE WILL TAKE THEM INTO CUSTODY
AND THEN SEND THEM BACK TO A
PORT OF ENTRY OR OTHER MEANS.
IT WILL BE VERY QUICKLY, IT WILL
NOT BE THE SIX OR SEVEN OR TEN
DAYS THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE, IT
WILL BE MUCH MORE RAPID.
>> Reporter: OTM, WILL THEY BE
TAKEN TO AN AIRFIELD?
>> THAT IS CORRECT.
ABSOLUTELY.
>> Reporter: MR. PRESIDENT,
THE CHECK TO AMERICANS, YEARS OF
CHECKS AND INCOMES, DO YOU
BELIEVE --
>> President Trump: I BELIEVE
IN A LOT OF THINGS.
I WANT TO GIVE WORKERS MONEY.
WHICHEVER IS THE BEST WAY TO GET
IT.
AND I WANT TO KEEP THE BUSINESS
IS OPEN TOO APPEARED WITHOUT
BUSINESSES, THEY WILL NOT GET
MONEY FOR VERY LONG.
IF NOT, WE WILL DO SOMETHING
LATER, I'M SURE.
>> Reporter: THE ANALYSTS ARE
LOOKING AT UNREPORTED NUMBERS
THAT COULD SKYROCKET NEXT WEEK,
BY ANALYSTS SAY NEARLY 3 MILLION
PEOPLE APPLYING FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT.
THAT WOULD BE A HISTORIC NUMBER.
IS A $1,000 CHECK GOING TO CUT
IT?
>> President Trump: WE ARE NOT
TALKING ABOUT A $1,000 CHECK, WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT MUCH MORE THAN
THAT.
WE ARE ALSO TALKING ABOUT DOING
PHASES.
IF THIS DOES NOT WORK, WE WILL
KEEP GOING UNTIL WE GET IT
GOING.
ONCE WE GET THE ECONOMY BACK END
ONCE THE ENEMY IS DEFEATED.
THE INVISIBLE ENEMY, AS I CALL
IT.
ONCE IT IS DEFEATED AND WE GET
THE ECONOMY BACK, IT WILL COME
BACK VERY QUICKLY.
WE HAVE A TREMENDOUS ECONOMY.
WE DO NUMBERS LIKE NO OTHER
COUNTRY HAS EVER DONE BEFORE.
NUMBER ONE IN THE WORLD IF YOU
GO BACK TWO WEEKS.
AND STILL, OBVIOUSLY.
BUT IF YOU GO BACK TWO WEEKS,
NUMBER ONE IN THE WORLD BY FAR.
THAT MONEY COMES BACK VERY
RAPIDLY.
WE WANT TO HAVE IT SO THAT WHEN,
NOT IF, BUT WHEN WE WIN THE WAR
WITH THE INVISIBLE ENEMY, WHEN
WE WIN IT, THE COMPANY IS CAN
IMMEDIATELY START.
NOT THAT THEY HAVE TO START
REBUILDING, THAT TAKES A LONG
TIME.
YOU SEE.
YOU KNOW, I GOT THAT.
>> Reporter: WHAT ARE YOUR
PROJECTIONS FOR JOB LOSSES IN
MARCH AND APRIL THAT YOU ARE
HEARING?
>> President Trump: WE LOOK AT
DIFFERENT NUMBERS, WE HAVE A
BEST CASE, NOT BEST CASE, BUT
THE BIG THING IS TO DEFEAT THE
VIRUS.
ONCE IT IS DEFEATED, STEVE, I
THINK THAT EVERYTHING ELSE FALLS
IN PLACE VERY RAPIDLY.
YOU WILL HAVE A TREMENDOUS
UPSWING, A LOT OF PEOPLE AGREE
WITH ME.
IF YOU LOOK AT YOUR STOCK MARKET
GENIUSES AND SOME OF WHOM ARE
NOT GENIUSES, BUT THEY THINK
THEY ARE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE THINK THAT I AM
RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
ONCE WE DEFEAT THE VIRUS, I
THINK YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A
VERY STEEP, LIKE A ROCKET SHIP
THAT WILL GO UP, AND EVERYTHING
WILL BE BACK.
AND I REALLY BELIEVE THAT WE
WILL BE STRONGER THAN EVER
BEFORE.
YES, GO AHEAD.
>> Reporter: ON THE SUPPLIES
COMING AT TOLD GOVERNORS TO FIND
WHATEVER SUPPLIES THEY COULD ON
THEIR OWN, BUT SOME ARE SAYING
WHEN THEY GO TO BUY THEM, THEY
ARE SEEING THE SIDE EFFECTS OF
GOVERNMENT.
>> President Trump: WELL, YOU
HEARD MY NEWS CONFERENCE
YESTERDAY, THEY WENT TO BUY
SUPPLIES, AND WE WANT TO BUY AS
A BACK UP, SOMETIMES THAT WILL
HAPPEN, BUT REGARDLESS OF WHO
GETS THEM WHEN THEY NEED THEM,
WE ARE GETTING THEM TO THEM.
WE ARE DOING THE PRODUCTION AND
VERY MUCH, WE HAVE A LOT OF
THINGS COOKING RIGHT NOW AT A
HIGH LEVEL.
REMEMBER THIS, NOTHING LIKE THIS
HAS EVER HAPPENED BEFORE.
OVER 140 COUNTRIES, AND YOU HAVE
SUPPLY CHAINS THAT HAVE BROKEN
DOWN FOR TWO REASONS, BECAUSE IT
CAN'T SUPPLY THAT MUCH, AND
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE SICK.
THEY CAN'T BE ON THE CHAIN.
IF THEY HAVE THINGS AROUND THE
WORLD.
BECAUSE OF THE ILLNESS AND ALSO
BECAUSE OF THE QUANTITY.
BUT WE ARE GETTING IT ORDERED.
WE ARE GETTING IT DONE.
AND IF YOU JUST -- LOOK, SOME OF
YOU WERE AT THE CALL YESTERDAY
WHERE I SPOKE WITH THE
GOVERNORS, OR MOST ALL OF THE
GOVERNORS, AND EVERY ONE OF THEM
WAS VERY IMPRESSED WITH WHAT WE
HAVE DONE.
GO AHEAD, IN THE MIDDLE.
>> Reporter: WHAT ABOUT THE
LABOR DEPARTMENT TELLING STATES
NOT TO DISCLOSE THEIR
UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS, DO YOU
AGREE WITH THAT?
>> President Trump: I WOULD
HAVE TO TALK TO THEM.
>> Reporter: ON THE BPA, I
JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR, ARE YOU
SAYING THE ADMINISTRATION IS
REQUIRING THE INDUSTRIES TO
CREATE THE PROJECTS?
>> President Trump: IT IS AN
AMAZING THING THAT HAPPENED, WE
ARE GETTING CALLS FROM
AUTOMOBILE COMPANIES AND OTHER
COMPANIES SAYING THEY HAVE
PLANNED CAPACITY, THEY WANT TO
MAKE BETTER LEADERS AND OTHER
THINGS, WE ARE BEING BESIEGED IN
A BEAUTIFUL WAY BY COMPANIES
THAT WANT TO DO THE WORK.
THEY WANT TO DO THE JOB.
THEY WANT TO HELP US AND OUR
COUNTRY.
SO WE HAVE NOT HAD A PROBLEM
WITH THAT AT ALL.
>> Reporter: MR. PRESIDENT,
HOW DO YOU HELP OUT STATES AND
LOCALITIES THAT ARE TRYING TO
BID ON THINGS LIKE VENTILATORS
AND OTHER ITEMS, WHETHER THEY
ARE BEING OUTFITTED --
>> President Trump: WHEN THEY
CALL US, THEY LET US KNOW.
IF THERE WAS A CONFLICT, THEY
WILL CALL US AND WE WILL DROP
THE BID, BECAUSE WE WANT THEM TO
GO FIRST.
BECAUSE THEY ARE THE POINT OF
SALE.
WE HAVE HAD FOUR OR FIVE
INSTANCES, WHERE LITERALLY THAT
WAS HAPPENING, BECAUSE WE ARE
BOTH TRYING TO GET STOCK.
AND IF WE ARE GOING AGAINST,
THEY WILL CALL US, THE SMART
ONES, FRANKLY, THEY WILL CALL
US.
AND WE IMMEDIATELY WANT THEM TO
BUY IT.
BECAUSE IT GETS TO THEM QUICKER
IF THEY BUY IT.
THEY KNOW THAT.
AND IT IS HAPPENING MORE AND
MORE WHEN THEY ARE CALLING AND
SAYING WE ARE BIDDING AGAINST
EACH OTHER, THEY WANT TO GET IT,
THEY WILL GET IT MUCH QUICKER
THAT WAY.
GO AHEAD, CHRIS.
>> Reporter: MR. PRESIDENT, A
QUESTION FOR THE SECRETARY,
THERE ARE LOTS OF COUNTRIES THAT
DON'T HAVE THE TESTING SUPPLIES
THEY NEED, WHAT SPECIFIC
ACTIONS --
>> President Trump: I CAN TELL
YOU THAT IT IS GOING VERY WELL.
WE HAVE MADE A GOOD THING OUT OF
IT.
I'VE NOT HEARD THAT QUESTION IN
A WHILE, BUT GO AHEAD.
>> SO FIRST, AND WE ARE MAKING
TREMENDOUS PROGRESS IN TERMS OF
LAB TESTING.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF TESTS ARE
BEING DONE EVERY SINGLE DAY BOTH
THROUGH THE CDC AND THE PUBLIC
HEALTH LABS AS WELL AS NOW
THROUGH THE PRIVATE SECTOR
COMMERCIAL LABS.
THEY ARE GETTING THE SCALE.
THEY HAVE SUPPLIES.
THEY HAVE HIGH PROOF.
WE DO HERE AND IT TOWED A GLEE
OF A PUBLIC HEALTH LABS OR
ANOTHER ONE THAT HAS A CONCERN
ABOUT THIS SUPPLY OR THAT
SUPPLY.
BUT THROUGH FEMA, WE ACTUALLY
ARE STANDING UP A LABORATORY
TASK FORCE TO ANSWER THOSE
QUESTIONS.
USUALLY IT IS THAT THE LAB
PEOPLE DO NOT UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY ARE ACTUALLY ALTERNATIVE
SUPPLIES IN THE MARKETPLACE THAT
THEY ARE PERFECTLY FREE TO USE.
WE HAVE HAD TO PUT OUT SOME
COMMON MYTHS AND TRUTHS ABOUT
THAT.
THE OTHER DAY, WE WERE GETTING
CALLS FROM GOVERNORS SAYING WE
DON'T HAVE SWABS, THEY ARE NO
SWABS.
OUR SUPPLIES PEOPLE WENT IN THE
OPEN MARKET PLACE AND BOUGHT
200,000 SWABS IN THE MARKET, AND
I SENT A LETTER TO GOVERNORS
WITH THE SWABS.
SO THEY ARE NOT LISTENING OR
CHECKING WITH US ABOUT ALL THE
FREEDOM, ALL THE CAPACITY IS OUT
THERE.
IT IS A COMPLEX SYSTEM WITH 330
AMERICANS AND ALL OF THE LABS.
SO SOMETIMES THERE IS A LAB THAT
DOES NOT UNDERSTAND HOW MUCH
FLEXIBILITY THEY HAVE AND HOW
MUCH SUPPLY IS OUT THERE.
WE ARE WORKING THROUGH THE FEMA
INTEGRATION CENTER TO HELP
CREATE THAT.
>> AS I SAID, MORE AND MORE
TESTS ARE BEING PERFORMED EVERY
DAY, AS WE LEARN ABOUT THE
RESULTS THAT ARE BEING REPORTED
AROUND THE COUNTRY OF
CORONAVIRUS TESTS, OUR EXPERTS
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THE NUMBERS
AND SEE THAT SOME 90% OF
AMERICANS THAT ARE TESTED DO NOT
TEST POSITIVE FOR THE
CORONAVIRUS.
SO IT CAN GIVE YOU A SENSE OF
THE MAGNITUDE OF TESTING THAT IS
GOING ON WITH THE NUMBER OF
CASES THAT WE HAVE REPORTED
TODAY AND IN SOME CASES IT IS
NEAR TEN TIMES THAT IT HAS BEEN
TESTED.
BUT LET ME SAY HOW IMPORTANT IT
WAS IN ANSWERING THESE QUESTIONS
FOR GOVERNORS AND LOCAL
OFFICIALS THAT THE PRESIDENT
STOOD UP FEMA.
AND THE NATIONAL RESPONSE CENTER
WHERE WE BRIEFED GOVERNORS
YESTERDAY.
NOW, EVERY GOVERNOR AND THE
STATE DEPARTMENT, STATE HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS HAVE THE ABILITY TO
REACH OUT TO OUR REGIONAL FEMA
ADMINISTRATORS, AND THAT'S HOW
AS THE PRESIDENT SAID, WE ARE
SORTING OUT THOSE POTENTIAL
CONFLICTS BETWEEN VERY
SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL PURCHASES
AND PROCUREMENTS, AND HOSPITALS
AND STATE GOVERNMENTS ARE
PURCHASING AS WELL.
I THINK THE NEW STREAMLINED
SYSTEM OPERATING NOW IN ALL 50
STATES ON THE TERRITORIES OF
GOVERNORS AND STATES GOING
THROUGH THE REGIONAL
ADMINISTRATOR FOR FEMA IS GOING
TO MAKE IT MORE POSSIBLE FOR US
TO ENSURE THAT OUR HOSPITALS ARE
HELPING PROVIDERS HAVE ACCESS TO
WHAT IS AVAILABLE ON THE OPEN
MARKET AND ELSEWHERE.
>> Reporter: YOU ARE HEADED
THE TASK FORCE AND YOU HAVE SEEN
THE NUMBERS, SPEAKING TO AVERAGE
AMERICANS, WHAT DO YOU SAY TO
AMERICANS WHO ARE WATCHING AND
IT SCARED?
>> Vice President Pence: I
WOULD SAY, DO NOT BE AFRAID, BE
VIGILANT.
ALL OF THE EXPERTS TELL US THAT
THE RISK OF SERIOUS ILLNESS IN
THE AVERAGE AMERICAN FOR THE
CORONAVIRUS IS LOW.
BUT WE NEED EVERY AMERICAN TO
PUT INTO PRACTICE THE
PRESIDENT'S CORONAVIRUS
GUIDELINES, 15 DAYS TO SLOW THE
SPREAD.
BECAUSE THE CORONAVIRUS IS ABOUT
THREE TIMES MORE CONTAGIOUS THAN
THE FLU ACCORDING TO OUR BEST
ESTIMATE, AND YOU CAN CONTRACT
THE CORONAVIRUS, HAVE VERY MILD
SYMPTOMS IF ANY, NOT EVEN BE
AWARE THAT YOU HAVE IT AND
EXPOSE SOMEONE WHO IS VULNERABLE
TO A VERY SERIOUS HEALTH
OUTCOME.
THAT'S THE REASON WHY WE ARE
ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO AVOID
GROUPS OF MORE THAN TEN, TO NOT
EAT IN RESTAURANTS, BUT TO USE
DRIVE-THROUGH'S, WASH THEIR
HANDS ON A REGULAR BASIS AND
PARTICULARLY WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE AS THE PRESIDENT HAS
DIRECTED US TO FOCUS ON THE MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION, WHICH ARE
SENIORS WITH SERIOUS UNDERLYING
HEALTH CONDITIONS OR ANYONE WITH
AN UNDERLINING IMMUNODEFICIENCY.
IT IS THOSE PEOPLE THAT WE NEED
TO CARE FOR, BUT IT IS GOING TO
TAKE ALL OF US WORKING TOGETHER
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE SAFE.
>> Reporter: YOU JUST SAID
THAT YOU HAVE NOT HAD TO REQUIRE
COMPANIES TO UP THEIR PRODUCTION
OF MEDICAL SUPPLIES, BUT YOU
SAID LAST NIGHT THAT YOU INVOKED
THE BPA, I AM CONFUSED ON THE
REQUIREMENT?
>> President Trump: WHEN WE
MEET SOMETHING, WE ORDER
SOMETHING.
AND AS YOU KNOW, TWO DAYS AGO I
INVOKED THE ACT WHICH WAS A BIG
STEP, I'M NOT SURE THAT IT HAD
BEEN DONE BEFORE OR AS MUCH, AND
WHEN WE DO SOMETHING, WE USE THE
ACT.
WHAT HAPPENS IS BEFORE WE GO
OUT, MANY, MANY COMPANIES.
GREAT COMPANIES IN A DIFFERENT
BUSINESS ARE WILLING TO DO
THINGS AND MAKE THINGS, BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO.
THEY MAKE PRODUCT.
THEY ARE WILLING TO MAKE PRODUCT
FOR US, MEDICAL PRODUCT THAT WE
NEED VERY BADLY FOR THE STATES
THAT THE STATES CAN'T GET TO.
THEY NOT BEEN ABLE TO GET.
MOST OF THE STATES IN NO WAY DID
THEY DO ANYTHING WRONG, THEY
WERE STOCKED UP.
THEY WERE ALL EQUIPPED.
UNFORTUNATELY THEY HAVE NEVER
HAD A THING LIKE THIS.
THEY NEED HELP FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
>> Reporter: YOU HAVE NOT
DIRECTED ANY COMPANIES TO START
MAKING MORE VENTILATORS OR
MASKS?
>> President Trump: I HAVE.
YES, I HAVE.
THEY HAVE BEEN MAKING A LOT OF
VENTILATORS AND A LOT OF MASKS.
>> Reporter: MR. PRESIDENT,
PARTIALLY FOLLOWING UP ON THAT,
ARE THERE AUTOMAKERS RIGHT NOW
WHO ARE RE-POOLING THEIR
PRODUCTION FACILITIES, WITH
VENTILATORS.
>> President Trump: I CANNOT
SAY THAT THEY ARE, BUT WE ARE
WORKING WITH ONE IN PARTICULAR
WHO MAKE VENTILATORS, THEY
CALLED US YESTERDAY AND THEY
WERE ABLE TO BE WORKING ON A
TRANSACTION, THEY ARE GOING TO
MAKE VENTILATORS.
THEY SAY THAT THEY HAVE DONE IT
BEFORE, WHICH SURPRISED ME, BUT
THEY CAN DO IT VERY EASILY.
>> Reporter: HERE IS FOR
SECRETARY AZAR, YOU SAID
YESTERDAY THAT YOU FOCUSED A
CARNIVAL CORPORATION CHAIRMAN,
AND HE SAID THAT HE COULD DONATE
SOME SHAPES.
>> President Trump: HE IS NOT
GIVING THEM.
HE IS GOING TO LET US USE THEM.
MICKEY HARRISON, WHO IS THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO AND OWNER.
>> Reporter: AND HE HAD SOME
SHAPES --
>> President Trump: HE SAID TO
ME THAT HE WAS WILLING TO IF WE
NEED SHIPS, IF WE NEED SHIPS FOR
HELPING PEOPLE, THAT CARNAVAL
WILL BE ABSOLUTELY WILLING TO
HELP US IN LOS ANGELES AND
NEW YORK, WHEREVER THEY MAY BE,
AND MIAMI, WHEREVER THEY ARE
VERY BIG, IF THEY NEED
SOMETHING.
SO FAR WE HAVE NOT NEEDED TO
COME AND WE ARE BRING IN THE
HOSPITAL SHIPS UP IN CALIFORNIA,
WE ARE WORKING WITH THE GOVERNOR
OF CALIFORNIA, WITH GAVIN, AND
WE HAVE NOT MADE A
DETERMINATION.
WE ARE TALKING TO FOLKS IN
SEATTLE.
WE ARE DISCUSSING WHERE IT CAN
BE MOST USEFUL.
WE HAVE SPOKEN WITH THE
GOVERNOR CUOMO, AND WE ARE
BRINGING THE HOSPITAL IP UP IN
TWO WEEKS AND WE WILL HAVE IT IN
NEW YORK HARBOR.
>> Reporter: THE QUESTION IS,
ONE, IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU HAVE NOT
TAKEN THEM UP ON IT --
>> President Trump: I SAID IF
WE DO NEED IT, I WILL LET YOU
KNOW.
RIGHT NOW WE DON'T NEED IT.
>> Reporter: SECONDLY THERE
ARE REPORTEDLY CONTACTED
INTEREST IS, AND THIS IS WHERE
YOU COME IN, SECRETARY AZAR, DO
YOU HAVE THE PLACE IS BEING USED
AS HOSTELS?
>> President Trump: I CAN TELL
YOU THAT THEY ARE VERY CLEAN,
AND THE VIRUS DISAPPEARS OVER A
PERIOD OF TIME, AND THEY SHIPS
ARE VERY CLEAN.
THEY'VE BEEN KEPT VERY CLEAN.
THEY'VE BEEN GONE OVER, BUT THE
VIRUS AS YOU KNOW IF IT IS ON
THE SURFACE, THEY HAVE CHARTS OF
DIFFERENT KIND OF SURFACES, IT
DISAPPEARS OVER A PERIOD OF
TIME.
WHAT ARE YOU TRYING TO GET AT?
GO AHEAD.
IT DISAPPEARS, THE VIRUS
DISAPPEARS WHEN IT IS ON SURFACE
AFTER A CERTAIN NUMBER OF DAYS,
OR IN SOME CASES HOURS DEPENDING
ON THE SURFACE.
>> Reporter: A QUICK
FOLLOW-UP, CAN YOU NAME ANY OF
THE COMPANIES THAT YOU HAVE
ASKED TO START MAKING THESE
VENTILATORS OR FACE MASKS?
>> President Trump: I WILL BE,
BUT I WANT APPROVAL FROM THE
COMPANY.
I ASSUME THEY WOULD LIKE IT, BUT
I WILL LET YOU KNOW.
>> Reporter: THIS IS FOR
DR. FAUCI --
>> President Trump: THE ONE
COMPANY THAT IS OPENLY SAID SO
IS GENERAL MOTORS.
>> Reporter: DID YOU ASK
GENERAL MOTORS?
>> President Trump: I WILL ASK
THEM, BUT WE HAVE OTHERS ALSO.
>> Reporter: AND SO FOR
DR. FAUCI, THERE IS NEW
INFORMATION THAT THE CDC HAS A
RELEASE THAT 13% OF THE PEOPLE
WITH THE CORONAVIRUS ARE SOMEONE
THAT ARE ASYMPTOMATIC.
SO DOES THAT CHANGE THE APPROACH
THAT YOU WOULD TAKE?
AND DO YOU THINK THAT -- OR DO
YOU NOT THINK THAT THAT SHOULD
CHANGE?
>> THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ARE
HERE APPLIES TO WHETHER YOU ARE
IN PHYSICAL CONTACT WITH SOMEONE
WHO COULD BE INFECTED WITH
SYMPTOMS VERSUS ASYMPTOMATIC.
I DON'T REALLY THINK IT CHANGES
ANYTHING.
CERTAINLY THERE IS SOME DEGREE
OF ASYMPTOMATIC
TRANSMISSIBILITY.
IT IS STILL NOT QUITE CLEAR
EXACTLY WHAT THAT IS.
BUT WHEN PEOPLE FOCUS ON THAT,
THEY TAKE THEIR EYE OFF THE REAL
BALL, WHICH ARE THE THINGS THAT
YOU DO WILL MITIGATE AGAINST
GETTING INFECTED, NO MATTER
WHETHER YOU ARE NEAR SOMEONE WHO
IS ASYMPTOMATIC OR NOT.
IT IS THE SAME THING.
PHYSICAL SEPARATION IN THE CARE
IS GOING TO TAKE CARE OF BOTH OF
THOSE THINGS.
>> Reporter: THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT, I HAVE A QUESTION
ABOUT TESTING, WHEN WILL EVERY
AMERICAN WHO NEEDS A TEST, GET A
TEST, AND WHY NOT HAVE MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT BEING SHIPPED RIGHT
NOW TO HOSPITALS WHO NEED IT?
>> President Trump: WE ARE
HEARING VERY POSITIVE THINGS
ABOUT TESTING, JUST SO YOU
UNDERSTAND, WE DON'T WANT EVERY
AMERICAN TO GO OUT AND GET A
TEST.
360 MILLION PEOPLE, WE DON'T
WANT THAT.
WE WANT PEOPLE THAT HAVE A
PROBLEM, THAT HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH, THEY ARE SNEEZING, THEY
ARE SNIFFLING, THEY DON'T FEEL
GOOD, THEY HAVE A TEMPERATURE,
THERE A LOT OF DIFFERENT THINGS.
YOU KNOW THEM BETTER THAN I DO,
WE DON'T NEED THAT.
BUT WE WE ARE HAVING IS HAVING
THESE PRIVATE LABS THAT HAVE
COME IN AND BEEN REALLY
FANTASTIC, AND WE ALSO HAVE A
GREAT SYSTEM FOR THE FUTURE,
BECAUSE AS I SAID, WE INHERITED,
WEAK, MEANING THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND OBSOLETE,
BROKEN SYSTEM THAT WAS NOT MEANT
FOR ANYTHING LIKE THIS.
NOW WE HAVE A SYSTEM THAT YOU
CAN SEE, BECAUSE LOOK, WE ARE
WELL INTO THIS, AND NOBODY IS
EVEN TALKING ABOUT IT EXCEPT FOR
YOU, WHICH DOES NOT SURPRISE ME.
>> Reporter: THERE ARE
AMERICANS THAT CANNOT GET THERE,
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THEM?
>> President Trump: WE DON'T
WANT EVERYBODY TO GO OUT AND GET
A TEST.
THERE IS NO REASON FOR IT.
WE WILL DO ONE MORE AFTER THIS.
>> Reporter: THIS IS FOR
DR. FAUCI, THEY ARE MORE PEOPLE
THAT ARE SUGGESTING THAT THE
REAL WAY TO GET TO THE END OF
THIS, FOR LIFE TO RETURN TO
NORMAL IS FOR EVERY SINGLE
PERSON IN THE COUNTRY TO BE
TESTED, THAT WAY YOU CAN SEE WHO
IS IN CONTAGIOUS AND THEN YOU
CAN HAVE PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE A
GO BACK TO WORK, IS THERE ANY
POSSIBILITY THAT THE COUNTRY
COULD EVER GET TO A POINT WHERE
EVERY SINGLE PERSON COULD BE
TESTED AND HOW LONG WOULD THAT
TAKE?
>> THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION, I
HAVE HEARD THAT BEFORE, I DON'T
CONNECT THE DOTS.
I DON'T SEE HOW TESTING
EVERYBODY IN THE COUNTRY IS
GOING TO HELP YOU TO IMPLEMENT
THIS.
THIS SHOULD BE IMPLEMENTED
UNIVERSALLY.
AT LEAST AT THIS LEVEL FOR
EVERYONE.
THE THINGS THAT WE SPOKE ABOUT A
WHILE AGO, THAT YOU WANT TO
REALLY RATCHETED UP LIKE
GOVERNOR NEWSOM IS DOING IN
CALIFORNIA, LIKE GOVERNOR CUOMO
IN NEW YORK, OR HOW YOU PUT AN
END TO THIS OUTBREAK, TESTING IS
IMPORTANT.
IT WOULD BE NICE TO KNOW, AND
THERE ARE CERTAIN THINGS THAT
YOU COULD DO.
BUT LET'S NOT CONFLATE TESTING
WITH THE ACTION THAT WE HAVE TO
TAKE.
WHETHER OR NOT YOU TEST, DO
THIS, I'M NOT PUTTING DOWN
TESTING AS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE.
BUT PEOPLE SEEM TO LINK THEM SO
MUCH THAT IF YOU DON'T HAVE
UNIVERSAL TESTING, YOU CAN'T
RESPOND TO THE OUTBREAK.
YOU REALLY CAN.
>> President Trump: AND I DO
THINK, AFTER LISTENING TO TONY
AND EVERYBODY ELSE THAT IS AN
EXPERT, I DO THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT NOT EVERYBODY BE
TESTED.
IF YOU FEEL GREAT AND IF YOU
HAVE NO SYMPTOMS WHATSOEVER, IT
IS JUST NOT A GOOD THING TO BE
DOING.
>> Reporter: THIS IS FOR
DR. FAUCI, YESTERDAY YOU TALKED
ABOUT AEROSOL TRANSMISSION OF
THE VIRUS, HOW LIKELY IS THAT
FOR HAPPENING?
>> THE LIKELIHOOD OF AEROSOL
TRANSMISSION COMES UP WHEN YOU
HAVE SITUATIONS LIKE THAT, IT
COMES UP WITH THE INFLUENCE IT
CAME UP WITH SARS IN WHICH THERE
WAS A DOCUMENTED ONE OFF EPISODE
OF AN AEROSOL TRANSMISSION.
THAT MEANS THAT IT CAN STAY IN
THE AIR FOR A PERIOD OF TIME
BECAUSE OF A DROPLET THAT IS
VERY SMALL AND DOES NOT GO DOWN.
IS IT POSSIBLE THAT THERE IS
AEROSOL TRANSMISSION?
WELL, YES, IT CERTAINLY IS, BUT
CLEARLY WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IN THE
SITUATIONS WITH PEOPLE GETTING
INFECTED FROM THE AREAS THAT WE
HAVE EXPERIENCE, CHINA,
SOUTH KOREA, NOW EUROPE.
MOST OF IT IS IN SITUATIONS
WHERE PEOPLE ARE CLOSE ENOUGH TO
EACH OTHER THAT A SYSTEMATIC
PERSON WILL HAVE A REAL DROPLET
TRANSMISSION.
SO I'M NOT RULING OUT TO THE
POSSIBILITY THAT IT IS AEROSOL,
BUT AGAIN, IT IS NOT GOING TO
SUBSTANTIALLY CHANGE DOING THIS.
>> Reporter: LET ME ASK THIS
IN A VERY SIMPLE WAY, WHAT IS
THE DEMAND PRESSURE ON TESTING
IN THIS COUNTRY AND ARE WE
MEETING IT?
>> I GET THE SAME CALLS THAT
MANY OF YOU GET.
THAT SOMEBODY GOES INTO A PLACE
WHO HAS A SYMPTOM AND WANTS TO
GET A TEST, AND FOR ONE REASON
OR OTHER, MULTIPLE LOGISTIC
TECHNICAL, WHATEVER, THEY CANNOT
GET IT.
THAT IS A REALITY THAT IS
HAPPENING NOW.
IS IT THE SAME AS IT WAS A FEW
WEEKS AGO?
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
BECAUSE OF THE SECRETARY END AS
OTHERS HAVE SAID, RIGHT NOW THAT
WE HAVE THE PRIVATE SECTOR
INVOLVED, THE AVAILABILITY OF A
NOT ONLY JUST AVAILABILITY, BUT
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
AVAILABILITY IS GETTING BETTER
AND BETTER AND BETTER.
HAVING SAID THAT, I UNDERSTAND
AND EMPATHIZE WITH THE PEOPLE
WHO RIGHTFULLY ARE SAYING, I AM
TRYING TO GET A TEST, AND I
CAN'T.
>> IS THAT A WAY OF SAYING WE
ARE NOT YET AT THE POINT OF
MEETING THE PRESSURE.
>> THE ANSWER IS YES, JOHN, WE
ARE NOT THERE YET, OTHERWISE
PEOPLE WOULD NOT BE CALLING UP
SAYING THEY CAN'T GET A TEST.
>> Reporter: ESTHER
PRESIDENT  --
>> I CANNOT EMPHASIZE ENOUGH
ABOUT THE INCREDIBLE PROGRESS WE
HAVE MADE ON TESTING.
ALL OF YOUR REPORTING AND MEDIA
OUTLETS AROUND THE COUNTRY ARE
AS WELL THAT MANY, MANY MORE
TESTS ARE BEING PERFORMED EVERY
DAY.
LITERALLY BY THE TENS OF
THOUSANDS.
AND THIS IS ONLY POSSIBLE
BECAUSE SEVERAL WEEKS AGO THE
PRESIDENT BROUGHT IN THE
COMMERCIAL LABS, THESE ENORMOUS
COMPANIES, QWEST AND LAB CORE,
WORKING WITH COMPANIES LIKE
ROCHE AND ABBOT LABORATORIES,
THERMO FISHER, AND SAYING WE
HAVE THIS EXISTING SYSTEM OF
STATE LABORATORIES AND THE CDC
PROCESSING TEST FOR CERTAIN
INFECTIONS.
GIVEN THE MAGNITUDE OF THIS
OUTBREAK, THE PRESIDENT
APPREHENDED EARLY ON THAT IT
WOULD NOT BE ENOUGH TO MEET THE
NEED, AND I JUST WON EVERY
AMERICAN TO KNOW THAT LITERALLY
OUR BY OUR IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THESE COMMERCIAL LABS, WE
ARE MAKING MORE AND MORE TESTS
AVAILABLE EVERY DAY.
HE WILL DETAIL THE WAY THAT WE
ARE WORKING WITH STATES TO
DISTRIBUTE THOSE TESTS.
WE HAVE OBVIOUSLY FOCUSED ON
STATES THAT HAVE BEEN DEALING
WITH THE MOST SERIOUS OUTBREAKS
OF CORONAVIRUS.
WASHINGTON STATE, CALIFORNIA,
NEW YORK, AND OTHERS.
WE HAVE BEEN MAKING SURE THAT
THE TESTS ARE IN THOSE AREAS
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THOSE
GOVERNORS.
BUT I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
SHOULD BE ENCOURAGED THAT THE
PROGRESS THAT WE ARE MAKING.
TOMORROW WE WILL TAKE SOME TIME
TO DETAIL THAT PROGRESS FOR YOU.
BUT I WOULD SAY TO ANY AMERICAN
WHO MIGHT BE CONCERNED THAT THEY
HAVE SYMPTOMS, AS THE PRESIDENT
SAID SO WELL, WE DON'T WANT
EVERY HEALTHY AMERICAN TO GET A
TEST.
BUT IF PEOPLE FEEL THAT THEY
HAVE SYMPTOMS THAT THEY IDENTIFY
WITH THE CORONAVIRUS, CALL YOUR
DOCTOR.
THEIR DOCTOR CAN CALL THE STATE
HEALTH AUTHORITIES.
THEY CAN WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH
OUR ENTIRE TEAM THROUGH HHS AND
FEMA AND WORK TO IDENTIFY THEM
MORE AND MORE TESTS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE EVERY DAY.
>> President Trump: JUST SO
YOU KNOW, JUST FOR THE HUNDREDTH
TIME.
I COME OF THIS ADMINISTRATION
INHERITED AN OBSOLETE, BROKEN,
OLD SYSTEM THAT WAS NOT MEANT
FOR THIS.
WE DISCARDED THAT SYSTEM.
AND WE NOW HAVE A NEW SYSTEM
THAT CAN DO MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
AS YOU NEED THEM.
WE HAD TO GET RID OF A BROKEN
OLD SYSTEM THAT DID NOT WORK.
IT ONLY WORKED ON A LIMITED
BASIS.
AND WE ARE VERY PROUD OF WHAT WE
HAVE DONE.
IT IS INCREDIBLE WHAT WE HAVE
DONE.
AND THE SYSTEM WILL SERVE FOR
THE FUTURE, FOR FUTURE PROBLEMS.
HOPEFULLY YOU DON'T HAVE A
PROBLEM LIKE THIS, BUT SOME
THING WILL COME UP.
WE HAVE NOW A GREAT SYSTEM.
AND IT IS ALMOST FULLY IN GEAR,
BUT IT IS ABLE TO TEST MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE.
BUT WE INHERITED A BROKEN, OLD,
FRANKLY A TERRIBLE SYSTEM.
WE FIXED IT, AND WE HAVE DONE A
GREAT JOB.
AND WE HAVE NOT BEEN GIVEN THE
CREDIT THAT WE DESERVE.
THAT I CAN TELL YOU.
BUT THE ONE THAT REALLY DESERVES
THE CREDIT ARE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
BECAUSE THEY ARE DOING THINGS
THAT NOBODY THOUGHT THEY WOULD
DEAL.
WHAT THEY ARE DOING IS
INCREDIBLE.
AND WE ARE MAKING A LOT OF
PROGRESS, AND WE WILL SEE YOU
FOLKS TOMORROW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> Harris: WE HAVE BEEN
WATCHING THE PRESIDENT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
HERE ON THIS FOX BROADCAST
STATION.
REALLY QUICKLY, THREE LANES OF
INFORMATION THAT WE JUST GOT FOR
WELL OVER 90 MINUTES FROM THE
TASK FORCE WITH THE PRESIDENT
AND VICE PRESIDENT.
BIG, BIG HAPPENINGS IN NEW YORK
AND CALIFORNIA WITH MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE NOW IN A SITUATION WHERE
NONESSENTIAL WORKERS, MILLIONS
OF THEM ARE BEING TOLD NOT TO GO
TO WORK.
PEOPLE BEING TOLD TO STAY IN
THEIR HOMES.
WE HAVE GOTTEN TO THAT POINTOW